bonjour à tous les confiner bonsoir plus
exactement je ne sais pas ce qu'on dit à
cette heure ci et merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce facebook live a alors
jeu comme d'habitude je ne répondrai pas
nécessairement à toutes les questions
qui ont été posées et je remercie
joël et jean-pierre de les avoir triés
pour essayer d'en faire quelque chose
que je puisse éventuellement exploitées
alors comme tout bon démagogue qui se
respecte je vais commencer par prendre
celle qui a reçu le plus de votes et
celle qui a reçu le plus de votes elle
dit comment concilier transition est
donc possible aux fins de la croissance
économique avec la problématique de
l'emploi et la nécessité de générer du
revenu pour vivre
il se trouve que il ya maintenant
quelques années j'avais publié sur mon
site
une petite règle de trois donc une
variante de l'équation de kaya dont le
titre était peut-on concilier chômage en
baisse à énergie en baisse et emploi en
hausse si ma mémoire est bonne c'est
peut-être pas exactement dans cet ordre
là mais c'était exactement cette
question donc la question c'est comment
on fait pour créer plus de job avec un
pib qui baissent parce que l'énergie
baissent donc la raison première danse
est dans cette façon d'aborder la
question c'était la contraction
énergétique et donc la contraction
économique le la réponse est
malheureusement qu on ne sait pas faire
ça sans baisser le revenu par emploi
alors il ya deux manières de baisser le
revenu par emploi il ya de baisser les
revenus du capital ça ça permet de ne
pas toucher aux salaires donc on dit aux
gens qui gagnent de l'argent grâce à
leur capital messieurs on va vous tondre
c'est une bonne idée éventuellement
malheureusement c'est généralement pas
suffisant pour permettre d'augmenter
significativement ou de même de
conserver des salaires constant dans une
économie qui se contracte la deuxième
option c'est de trouver
c'est de faire en sorte que le revenu
par emploi baisse d'hier dit comme ça
c'est affreux c est effectivement
affreux quelques quel que j'ai envie de
dire quelques échappatoires auquel on
peut penser d'abord c'est moins affreux
si en même temps que son revenu baisse
ses charges baissent
or il se trouve que aujourd'hui une
large partie des charges sont des
charges immobilières de loyer donc ça ça
va reculer avec une autre question qui a
été posée qui et comment est ce qu'on
fait pour sortir les gens des villes
dans un monde dans le dans le monde post
carbone parce qu'à partir du moment où
on répartit mieux les gens et on a moins
besoin d'être entassés au même endroit
on général un des trucs qu'on arrive à
faire c'est à faire baisser les prix de
l'immobilier
mais le mais c'est pas suffisant
et on peut aussi imaginer baisser des
charges autres par exemple
l'alimentation c'est plus facile de
baisser les charges alimentaires si on a
chacun un endroit où on a trois poules
et un potager etc
donc il ya de ça ne peut s'envisager que
dans une société qui elle même se
réorganise profondément c'est évident
que ça ne marche pas dans un monde dans
lequel on reste organisée spécialement
et en termes d'activités productives
exactement comme on est aujourd'hui et
notamment tous dans les villes où tout
est marchand il est impossible d'accéder
dans les villes à quoi que ce soit dont
on ait besoin qu'ils ne soient pas
marchand en première approximation
il ya un troisième manière de faire ça
qui est de faire sortir les gens qui ont
des grosses erreurs quand ils sont vieux
de les remplacer par des gens qui ont
des plus petits salaires quand ils sont
jeunes et de faire en sorte que les gens
qui ont des petits salaires
lisez moins d'augmentation à
l'ancienneté que les gens vieux qui
sortent avec des gros salaires
donc ça c'est une fois ou avec des
salaires augmentent et on va dire donc
ce que je dis est une autre manière de
dire quelque chose de très désagréable
qui est qu' on n'a pas un salaire qui
augmente avec l'âge
alors je n'ai pas fait d'études
économiques poussé sur la façon dont
étaient organisés les revenus des
paysans parce qu'à l'époque c'était
essentiellement des paysans il ya
quelques siècles avant le début de la
révolution industrielle mais je serais
très étonné de découvrir que à cette
époque là les revenus augmenter avec
l'âge je pense que malheureusement ou
heureusement je ne sais pas le paysan de
l'époque ce qu'il gagne elle a 25 ans et
ce qu'ils gagnaient à 50 s'il était
toujours vivant c'était à peu près la
même chose ça pose donc une question du
rapport au temps et du rapport
l'augmentation avec le temps aujourd'hui
on considère tous comme normal y compris
dans la société que je co dirige qu'avec
le temps soit augmenté parce que on
gagne en expérience on gagne en soucier
en gagnant cela mais c'est quelque chose
de relativement récent ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas dans la société
ancienne
le problème que je viens d'évoquer pose
évidemment à ce moment un autre problème
en cascade qui est que si au moment où
les gros salaires sortent du système et
que je les remplace par des petits
salaires
une des choses qui ne faut pas que je me
avec un des problèmes que je vais avoir
à gérer c'est éventuellement d'avoir des
gens qui se retrouvaient les grosses
retraites ou plus exactement avec des
retraites qui sont excessives
donc là on tombe sur un autre effet
domino qui est qu'est ce que je fais
avec les retraites
et est ce que je considère que les
retraités etc 1re boucle aussi avec une
autre question qui a été posée
retourneront vivre chez leur enfant
commises comme comme pendant très très
longtemps on l'a fait c'est à dire que
pendant très longtemps quand on était
une société d'agriculteurs avec très peu
de gens en ville il n'y avait pas
d'éclatement familiale les enfants les
parents et les grands parents vivaient
au même endroit ce qu'on peut trouver
fort désagréable par les temps qui
courent je le concept tout à fait je
suis pas sûr que tout le monde soit ravi
à l'idée de gérer son beau père où sa
belle-mère mais par contre il est clair
que ça offrait des économies des espaces
ça offrait des économies de charges
donc ça offrait tout un tas davantage en
termes économiques que aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus à voir avec l'éclatement des
structures et quand en plus l'éclatement
des structures donne une prise en charge
par les collectivités des gens qui sont
plus chers du tout typiquement les ehpad
ou les à ce moment on a des charges qui
sont encore augmenter viens gagner
videmment donc la réponse douloureuse
à la question qui est posée sur comment
est-ce qu'on peut concilier un pib qui
se contracte avec plus d'emplois
la réponse douleureuse est
malheureusement qu il n'y a pas 36
manières de faveur
ça ne peut être fait qu avec un revenu
par emploi qui baisse et dans un souci
d'équité bien légitimement avec les
revenus les plus importantes qui
baissent plus vite que les revenus les
moins importants et les revenus du
capital qui baissent plus vite que les
revenus du travail voilà c'est ça en
gros lacan
la grande règle sahara boucle avec une
autre question qui a été posée dans la
liste qui était quid des économistes qui
travaillent sur ce genre de choses
alors il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'économistes qui travaille sur la
portée pratique de ce que je viens de
dire
il ya des économistes qui font de la
macroéconomie sous contrainte physique
le premier encore une fois tout le monde
le connaît peut-être dans les gens qui
écoutent ces meadows qui avait fait son
fameux modèle ou à trois il ya
maintenant quasiment 50 ans même 50 ans
et qui avait expliqué que alors l'époque
il appelait pas ça le pib il appelait ça
la production mais ça revient au même de
pib ne pouvait pas croître indéfiniment
dans un monde fini mais meadows n'est
pas allé jusqu à réfléchir aux règles
d'organisation de la société qui
permettent de gérer ce genre de
situation au moins mal ou mieux comme on
dit de telle sorte que ce soit pas une
société extrêmement durs à vivre pour
les gens qui s'y trouvent
je ne connais pas alors je suis peut
être mal informés mais je connais
aujourd'hui quelques économistes qui se
posent se pose la question de savoir
comment évolue le pib dans un monde
contre un sur le plan physique je ne
connais pas d'économistes qui est
travaillé sur la façon dont un pib qui
soit structurellement qui serait
structurellement en baisse peu se
répartir au mieux et comment est ce que
on organise au mieux la société dans ce
genre de contexte
c'est quoi le bon équilibre entre la
ville et la campagne c'est quoi le bon
équilibre entre la production et les
services c'est quoi le bon équilibre
entre la production d'objets de nouveau
et la réparation c'est quoi le bon
équilibre entre l'activité et la
retraite ou entre les études et
l'activité
voilà je pense que toutes ces questions
là aujourd'hui sont malheureusement des
questions totalement ouverte et la
mauvaise nouvelle pour boucler avec ce
que j'avais expliqué dans le dernier
facebook live c'est que à partir du
moment où personne n'a réfléchi à ça si
la situation se présente
et en ce moment elle se présente de
façon particulièrement aiguë eh bien
nous n'avons pas de plans d'urgence nous
n'avons pas de plan b pour réfléchir à
ce qu'on pourrait faire dans un contexte
pareil donc on va te donner quand on
tâtonne en général
on le voit dans d'autres domaines la
solution qu'on trouve en premier a peu
de chances d'être la bonne quelquefois
même la solution qu'on croit trouver
accroît le problème
donc là il est pas du tout exclu qu' on
rentre dans une période un peu
dangereuse dans laquelle on va croire
qu'on résout un problème facilement
alors que malheureusement on ne va pas y
arriver et l'une des choses qu'on va
probablement croire qu'on va arriver à
résoudre facilement c'est le retour de
la croissance alors oui après sept prix
- 8
on peut retourner sur une tendance
décroissante ans on propulse est l'année
d'après sa peau strictement aucun
problème mais enfin si l'on fait tous
les ans -8 puis toutes les années
d'après plus c'est depuis tous les ans
d'après encore moins huit fille tous les
ans après et c'est ça fait quand même
une tendance à la contraction
et cette tendance à la contraction je le
redis je l'avais déjà dit dans la foi
mon sentiment c'est qu'on n'en est pas
sorti notamment à cause de ce qui est en
train de se passer sur en ce moment sur
le pétrole où il va y avoir une partie
des capacités de production qui ne vont
pas être développée par ce que avec le
prix du baril actuelle personne n'aura
envie d'investir ce qui est une très
bonne nouvelle pour le climat mais une
très bonne une très mauvaise nouvelle
pour la réorientation après ce délai de
l'économie parce que on va
malheureusement déjà avoir les avoir
droit à une petite régulation
involontaire à la callas
c'est à dire que la baisse des émissions
de co2 sera provoquée par quelque chose
qui ne nous a rien demandé et qui tapera
essentiellement dans la population et
dans l'économie
ça va surtout taper dans l'économie et
pas dans les mesures qu'on pourrait
mettre oeuvre délibérément c'est-à-dire
efficacité sobriété décarbonation de
l'énergie voilà donc le longue réponse à
cette question courte qui et comment on
fait et bien la réponse est que
malheureusement on va te donner
mais pour avancer on est obligé de se
faire à l'idée que exactement comme
pendant une partie de sa vie au cours de
plus en plus vite et puis après on a de
moins en moins vite
là il ya eu une partie de l'histoire de
l'humanité pendant laquelle on gagner
plus en plus d'argent et puis là il faut
se faire à l'idée que avec le temps
enfin plutôt l inverse et qu'il faut
arriver à gérer cet effort collectif de
telle sorte qu'on se mette pas les uns
sur les autres ce qui n'est pas gagné
d'avancé
malheureusement alors j'avais une
deuxième question qui ressemblait un peu
qu'ils étaient avec avait aussi reçu
beaucoup de potes
en quoi est-ce que la récession changera
nos vies alors concrètement je me
retrouve au chômage
oui ça c'est un risque alors je dois
aussi je vais essayer de faire une
réponse qui soit un peu plus
circonstanciée si on imagine que la
tendance structurelle de la société
française à partir de maintenant c'est
que on n'est pas en croissance de 1% par
an mais qu'on est en récession de 1 %
par an nous mettons un ou deux si chacun
d'entre nous tous autant que nous sommes
on nous dit eh bien voilà vos charges et
vos recettes
donc ce que vous gagnez est ce que vous
payez diminue chaque année de 1 à 2% par
an
c'est pas nécessairement quelque chose
d'absolument dramatique c'est à dire que
1 ou 2% par an bon on va faire des
efforts sur ceux ci cela c'est voilà
c'est pas des séries dramatiques du côté
de la consommation
là où ça peut commencer à devenir
ennuyeux du côté production et donc du
côté emploi c'est si tout le monde fait
l'effort sur le même secteur
alors je vais prendre un exemple
peut-être caricatural mais pour bien
faire comprendre délibérément imaginons
que dans le cadre d'une baisse de 2% des
revenus par an tout le monde se disent
bon parce que je fais c'est que j'arrête
d'aller au cinéma
d'accord donc ce n'est pas très grave
pour moi voilà j'ai la télévision qui va
bien je regarderai la télévision si j'ai
pas la télévision j'ouvrirai mon
ordinateur
et puis je regarderai pas jancovici
parce qu'il déprime quelques uns des
autres c'est pas très grave au niveau
des habitudes de tout un chacun il n'y a
pas de problème avec ça par contre pour
les gens qui travaillent dans le cinéma
là ça fait tout de suite la pop la
totalité de la recette qui disparaissent
donc on va effectivement avoir je me
retrouve au chômage comme dans la
question mais ça va concerner une toute
petite partie de la population française
et c'est ça le problème en général en
termes de quand on a une récession c'est
que
la baisse des revenus et la baisse des
charges n'est pas homogène pour tout le
monde
en général les forces se concentrent sur
le maillon le plus faible
et c'est dans ce maillon faible qu'il va
y avoir des drames c'est ça c'est ça le
problème qui est à gérer quand on a une
récession si tout le monde allait 1% où
il n'a en moins bah ma foi les acteurs
se réveillait 1% de moins les
techniciens seraient payés 1 % de moins
les intermittents du spectacle au
chômage toucherait 1 % de moins et voilà
et tout ça se répartirait se répartirait
et se lie serait et bon an mal an on
finirait par y arriver on pourrait gérer
1 % de flux allant chaque année de la
ville devait encore de la ville
voilà tout à partir du moment où tout ça
est lissée sur l'ensemble de la société
on peut imaginer que le problème est
gérable exactement comme si je cours un
pour cent moins vite tous les ans c'est
quelque chose que j'arrive à gérer
là où ça devient pas gérable encore une
fois c'est quand ça se concentre sur un
seul secteur où là c'est pas moins d'un
pour cent on va se prendre du moins 50
ou du moins 30 ou 10 - 20 enfin près que
des pourcentages qui excède la capacité
à gérer le problème dans la joie et la
bonne humeur
donc la réponse à la question c'est que
si on a une récession tout le monde ne
se retrouve pas au chômage avec rihanna
manger etc
mais une partie des gens oui
effectivement risque de s'y retrouver
alors derrière qu'est-ce qui se passe eh
ben on comme dans une célèbre maxime de
mon école retourne sur le prime
précédent
c'est à dire que les gens qui sont au
chômage et qui ne devienne durablement
puisqu'on est en période de récession
structurelles donc on ne se dit pas
l'année prochaine les gens retourneront
si les masses ils ont pris l'habitude de
ne pas y aller parce que ils gagnent
moins d'argent mais ils vont plus ils
vont plus loin et donc ça veut dire que
les gens qui travaillent dans cette
filière doivent se reconvertir pour
devenir récolte asperges ou réparateur
de machines à laver et c'est là que la
puissance publique à tout son rôle à
jouer parce que les basculements
d'emplois il n'y a que la puissance
publique qui soit capable d'organiser ça
de manière un peu structurée quand ça
commence a concerné des grosses masses
tant que ça concerne la fluidité
naturelle du marchix travail on peut
faire confiance j'ai envie à l'économie
libérale
ça ça juste un peu ici quand ça commence
a concerné des vraiment grosse masse il
faut absolument que l'état s'en mêle
et que l'état fasse des choses qui ne
sont pas idiote pour que les transferts
s'opère de là où on n'a plus besoin de
gens vers là où on peut en avoir besoin
dans le cadre de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire dans le cadre quand
même de nouveaux emplois qui sont créés
et qui sont nécessairement puisqu'on est
en période de contraction moins
rémunérés que les emplois qui ont été
détruits et il faut à ce moment
s'assurer que les charges pour les gens
qui occupent ces emplois nouveaux ne
sont pas les mêmes ou supérieure à celle
qu'ils avaient avant mais inférieurs et
à ce moment là le système se rééquilibre
d'une autre manière que celle qu'on
avait l'habitude d'avoir
mais il se rééquilibre ont perdu à
d'autres fonctions il ya un autre sujet
qui va falloir gérer qui est que je n'ai
pas évoqué jusqu'à maintenant qui est le
sujet de la dette la dette est quelque
chose qui pour un certain nombre
d'acteurs se rembourse avec des revenus
réels c'est celle là qui pose problème
donc c'est la dette des agents privés
donc des entreprises et des particuliers
qui n'ont pas la possibilité de battre
monnaie et donc si vous avez un crédit
global sur le dos que vos revenus
baissent et ben vous êtes coincé vous
avez des échéances que vous n'êtes pas
capable de tenir
alors de là deux options ou bien l'état
à créer de la monnaie et payent pour
vous c'est un peu études option donc
c'est le rôle de l'état
ce qui revient à créer quelque part une
forme de monnaie de singe mais c'est pas
très grave
la banque perd un peu tout le monde perd
un peu dans cette histoire si c'est
l'état c'est pas grave l'état peut faire
de la dette perpétuelle du reste il est
en train de l'apprendre en ce moment et
donc l'état rembourse la dette avec une
nouvelle dette est dans un monde en
contraction par contre on va
probablement voir se généraliser les
taux négatifs ou l'équivalent une
passion qui redémarre au delà des taux
nominaux qui est une manière finalement
de faire de l'érosion lente et de ne pas
rembourser ses emprunts de façon lente
l'autre alternative c'est le défaut
alors le défaut c'est beaucoup grave
parce que ça c'est pour reprendre le
parallèle que j'avais pris tout à
l'heure entre un pour cent de baisse de
revenus pour tout le monde tout le temps
est
100 % de baisse de revenus pour un pour
cent de la population c'est évidemment
pas du tout pareil
eh bien là c'est exactement la même
chose à partir du moment où il ya des
défauts dans les remboursements là c'est
quelque chose qui fait des craquements
dans ce système qui parfois peuvent
réunir onde de choc très désagréable si
vous avez une érosion lente vous avez
payé durement donc vous avez de
l'épargné puis chaque année votre
épargne ou un peu moins cher parce que
vous n'avez rien d'autre que vous
puissiez en faire donc c'est comme ça le
pardon dans ce genre de cas de figure
ça revient quelque part à avoir une
inflation qui érode les revenus des
rentiers mais comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que dans un monde dans lequel il
y allait y avoir une récession
ce n'était pas idiot de tondre les
revenus du capital avant de tondre les
revenus du travail
finalement on dort processus qui
correspondrait à peu près c'est à dire
une lente érosion de la tête
le la récession est quelque chose qui
fait peur à l'état parce qu'il faut
rappeler que le pib c'est la base
fiscale et donc l'état n'aime pas du
tout la récession d'abord parce que ça
fait des chômeurs avec les chômeurs
c'est des électeurs par content et
ensuite dans la version actuelle et
ensuite parce que le pib c'est la base
fiscale et donc une récession c'est
moins d'impôts et donc un problème
budgétaire pour l'état qui optent pour
laquelle il n'aime pas ça et dominer
même pas ça eh bien il n'ya pas
d'économistes à bercy qui travaillent
sur cette hypothèse parce que le
ministre n'a aucune envie donc on nous
parlait de l'hypothèse en question alors
[Musique]
oui dans les questions qui arrivent là
la planche la planche à billets oui
c'est ça que l'état de la création
monétaire et avec la crise et les jours
depuis c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire c'est à dire que la bce la fed est
en train de faire ça et la bce va de fer
va être de fait pardon faire quelque
chose qui ressemble à ça
c'est à dire la création monétaire qui
va permettre aux états de continuer à
être endetté donc les états font vivre
avec une pyramide de ponzi qui va
croître et embellir pour un certain
temps et si on passe aux taux d'intérêts
négatifs en ce moment la pyramide de
ponzi se dégonflera doucettement avec en
final menton dans les gens qui ont prêté
et les gens prêteront peut-être parce
que entre perdre 2 % par an et tout
perdre parce que l'alternative se serait
tu perds beaucoup plus hachée par les
acceptant le père 2% par an ça revient à
une forme de monnaies fondantes qui est
aussi quelque chose qui a été envisagée
par certains par certains économistes
alors après il ya une question qui a
privé qui est qu'est ce qu'on fait dans
ce genre de contexte pour privilégier
une trajectoire de transition économique
bas carbone
je vais revenir là de nouveau à une
petite règle macroéconomique tout bête
vous avez en fait deux catégories de
pays qui sont très très différents en
terme de conséquences économiques de la
décarbonation de l'énergie
c'est les pays importateur
d'hydrocarbures et les pays exportateurs
d'hydrocarbures
il se trouve que la france est un pays
importateur d'hydrocarbures
nous produisons en france 1 % du pétrole
que nous consommons dans le bassin
parisien
je crois que nous ne produisons plus de
gaz du tout et je suis absolument
certain que nous ne produisons plus
d'uranium à plus de charbon du tout on
produit pas non plus notre uranium soit
dit en passant
la grosse différence entre l'uranium et
les combustibles fossiles c'est que le
radium on peut en stocker quelques
années ce qui géopolitiquement change
quand même beaucoup la donne et puis
physiquement change quand même où la
donne par rapport à un produit qu'on ne
stockez que quelques mois et encore des
comptables dans un tiers des stocks
stratégiques on commence vraiment à être
bien qu'ils sont trop loin
donc la question pour les importateurs
sait qu'on a une partie de marge qui est
macroéconomique mans indolore parts et
quand on arrive à faire des choses chez
nous pour se passer de combustibles
fossiles en les remplaçant par autre
chose qu'on arrive à trouver chez nous
en france il ya 2 j'ai envie de dire
décarbonation qui sont raisonnablement à
dos lors sur le plan économique
si on les attaque il ya la décarbonation
du chauffage on avait fait chez carbone
4 des petits calculs montrant que si on
remplaçait le chauffage au gaz et au
fioul par des pompes à chaleur même en
important les compresseurs parce
qu'aujourd'hui on les rapporte
on aurait un bénéfice macroéconomique
significatif dit autrement cette affaire
là créer de l'emploi
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
baisser les importations pour un usage
finale qui reste le même pour une
consommation qui reste la même
mécaniquement vous créer de l'emploi
al'inverse quand vous augmentez les
importations avec une consommation
finale qui reste la même
mécaniquement vous détruisez de l'emploi
dans l'ensemble de l'économie
vous n'êtes pas capables de savoir où
vous mais vous détruisez globalement de
l'emploi donc toute mesure de
décarbonation qui ne changent pas
beaucoup la consommation crée de
l'emploi donc un exemple encore une fois
c'est qu'à volume de bâtiments constants
donc là il s'agit pas d'en rajouter un
volume de bâtiments constants le passage
du gaz et du fioul à la pompe à chaleur
créée globalement de l'emploi
même s'il faut pour cela augmenter un
peu les importations d'uranium pour
faire un peu plus d'électricité
on a un deuxième cas de figure où on
pourrait créer de l'emploi c'est avec
l'électrification des voitures à masser
puissance identique alors c'est là qu'on
va tomber sur un problème parce que
justement c'est parce qu'il faut faire
si on si on les électrifie en faisant
les batteries chez nous si on les
électrifie en important les batteries
l'a de nouveau en détruit de l'emploi
parce que la batterie c'est quasiment la
moitié de la valeur du véhicule et donc
ça veut dire des implantations très
significative donc l'électrification
accélérée du parc
tant qu'on n'a pas des usines de
batteries chez nous c'est aussi une
mesure qui détruit de l'emploi ces macro
comme macroéconomique pas en france
c'est un truc qu'il faut avoir en tête
alors même que ça évite des importations
de pétrole
mais le pétrole c'est 15% du coût global
de la de la voiture alors que la
batterie c'est 50% ou tendres pour ça on
va dire du coût global de la voiture
quand on passe à l'électricité avec la
batterie pas chez nous vient au moment
où on fait ce basculement ont détruit
l'emploi c'est étonnant mais c'est une
réalité
donc on a des petites marges
après pour le reste ma foi on va
malheureusement tombé dans ce qui était
évoqué juste avant c'est à dire qu'on va
tomber dans un contexte dans lequel
décarbonés l'économie va se faire par de
la sobriété et la sobriété elle détruit
de l'emploi ou plus exactement elle
oblige si on veut conserver autant
d'emplois à ce qu'ils soient moins payés
je prends un exemple tout bête qui est
de passer de la voiture au vélo et plus
précisément au vélo électrique passer de
la voiture au vélo tout court c'est
quelque chose qui est pas facile il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'aiment pas trop
ça et c'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui de
plus en plus c'est les gens qui passent
de la voiture ou en vélo électrique
donc je connais quelques personnes dans
la banlieue où j'habite pas spécialement
sportifs entraînés et qui font
facilement 15 20 km en vélo électrique
ici sont bien trop de problèmes pour
aller au pour aller au travail
ces gens là peuvent à ce moment de deux
voitures par ménage passer à une voiture
par ménage sans aucun problème et donc
de leur côté c'est une action de
sobriété
donc je fais ça bien évidemment je
baisse les émissions mais par contre je
n'ai plus besoin des gens pour fabriquer
les voitures donc
quand je passe de la voiture au vélo
électrique je remplace une voiture qui
me coûte vingt mille euros par un veau
burckhardt ville par un vélo qui m'en
coûte entre 500 et 2000 donc bien
évidemment si je le garde la même durée
c'est aussi mon vélo me fait dix ans ou
15 ans comme voiture eh bien je vais
créer
je vais faire baisser le pib et la
sobriété fait baisser le pib puis ce que
j'achète mois pour que le raisonnement
aille jusqu'au bout il faut pas que je
dépense mon argent dans autre chose
donc si les 18000 euros que j'ai
économisé avec je pars en avion où je
m'en fous des gadgets électroniques
l'algérien d'éviter du tout mais si cet
argent je ne m'en sers pas détruit ou si
je suis dans un contexte dans lequel
j'ai gagné moins d'argent de toute façon
j'ai pas cet argent à dépenser
à ce moment j'ai un sujet enfin pas
danger dans l'économie dans son ensemble
on a une traction donc c'est bien c'est
bien ce sujet pour la sobriété et le
redéploiement d'une économie plus sobre
en carbone orienté autour de la sobriété
c'est que celle là elle les oblige à
faire des emplois qui sont moins payés
le la décarbonation qui n'oblige pas à
faire ce genre de choses c'est la
décarbonation qui permet de garder le
même volume de consommation par exemple
le même espace habitable où par exemple
les mêmes production industrielle qu'on
en rit électrifié en passant des
combustibles fossiles à l'électricité et
là on va arriver sur le sujet qui donne
des boutons à tout le monde c'est
beaucoup plus facile de le faire avec du
nucléaire que le fer avec des géants
diffusent pour des raisons physiques
mais ce n'est pas le but de la question
donc je ne m'étends pas là dessus mais
c'est une manière là d'avoir une
économie qui décroît moins vite et donc
c'est pour ça que j'utilise parfois le
cette expression que le nucléaire est un
parachute centrale parce qu'il permet
d'amortir la décroissance en conservant
une production et une consommation un
peu plus importante dit autrement en la
faisant décroître moins vite alors après
on peut considérer que c'est une
mauvaise chose parce qu'il faut que sa
décroissance en plus vite et au diable
la stabilité sociale ça n'est pas mon
avis moi je pense qu'il ya une voie
étroite à trouver entre la stabilité
sociale qu'il faut essayer de garder au
maximum et la contrainte
environnementale qui a le potentiel de
faire sauter la stabilité sociale
donc il ya une voie étroite pour
naviguer entre entre les deux voilà
après j'aime beaucoup la question qui
suit est ce qu'on est vraiment dans la
merde alors est ce qu'on est vraiment
dans la merde
un peu quand même bon tout ce que je
viens de raconter jusqu'à maintenant
montrent qu'il va pas y avoir
d'échappatoire est-il donc les gens qui
nous explique on va faire de la
croissance verte et que friser les
moustaches et les doigts dans le nez on
va repartir comme avant avec une
économie totalement décarbonés pouvoir
d'achat qui augmente malheureusement se
raconte des choses qui ne peuvent pas
arriver donc ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
va transpirer un grand coup est-ce que
c'est nécessairement une catastrophe
bah ça dépend encore une fois de la
façon dont ça se passe il ya longtemps
depuis que je présente l'équation callas
je me rappelle avoir souvent dit donc
pour ceux d'entre vous qui n'ont jamais
vu l'équation de kaya il ya une page sur
mon site perso jancovici point com qui
s'appelle qu'est-ce que l'équation de
kaya donc voilà c'est simple et ça n'est
pas un anagramme de yaka et cette
équation est une règle de trois qui
permet de mettre bout à bout les
émissions de co2 la population
l'économie et les mesures techniques
d'efficacité carbone ou énergétique de
l'économie et la conclusion de cette
équation
c'est que si on ne fait pas baisser les
émissions de co2 volontairement avec des
mesures techniques au moment où elle se
met à baisser involontairement parce
qu'on a plus assez de combustible
fossile a brûlé localement régionalement
ou mondialement à ce moment l'essentiel
de la baisse des émissions de co2 se
traduit par ce que c'est une baisse du
nombre de machines en fonctionnement en
baisse du pib par personne et
éventuellement en baisse de la
population donc le lien avec le co vide
enfin le lien on peut faire entre le
problème du réchauffement climatique et
la dépendance aux énergies fossiles et
duco vide c'est que personne ne pourra
jamais prouver et du reste je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit probable que le coc
vie d'un quelconque lien avec le
changement climatique
par contre c'est très facile de dire que
le genre de régulation qu'on a en ce
moment est illustratif du genre de
régulation involontaire qu'on aura si on
ne prend pas le taureau par les cornes
en ce qui concerne la dépendance de
l'économie aux combustibles fossiles
voilà c'est malheureusement ce genre de
choses qui nous attend de façon répétée
à l'avenir si on n'organise pas de nous
mêmes
la descente puisque c'est bien comme ça
qu'il faut l'appeler et des projets qui
sont compatibles avec une décroissance
du pib alors je le dis et je le répète
moi j'ai déjà vais prôner la
décroissance comme étant en tant que tel
un projet de société
je pense que ça ne marche pas pour
reprendre le parallèle de mon âme qui
courent où ma femme ma femme qui court
de tout à l'heure
jamais vous d'aller vendre à quelqu'un
qui pendant vingt ans s'est dit c'est
génial je cours de plus en plus vite ce
que c'est génial je cours de moins en
moins vite ce que vous arriverez à lui
vendre ses des projets qui ne nécessite
pas qu'ils courent de plus en plus vite
et qui s'accommode très bien du fait
qu'ils courent de moins en moins quitte
donc ça renvoie aussi à la question tout
à l'heure sur la façon de gérer la
société dans ce monde là il ya aussi un
forme de devoir pour tous les gens qui
sont concernés par ce sujet alors moi je
paie des pouvoirs paroisses et les
ingénieurs mais pas que les gens qui
organisent la société les sociologues
etc
il ya une forme de devoir peut-être plus
encore les sociologues que les
ingénieurs soit dit en passant il ya une
forme de devoir à penser l'organisation
de cette société et comment est-ce qu'on
peut l'organiser
j'ai envie de dire sans prononcer le
fruit décroissance mais on n'est pas
compatible avec c'est à dire on en ne
faisant pas de pari fou qui ne se
réaliseront pas sur les ressources dont
on va disposer pardon aussi un petit un
petit complément à ça alors par ailleurs
on est aussi dans la merde parce que
c'est pas parce qu'on a le coc vide en
ce moment et qu'on va avoir la
contraction économique que le changement
climatique s'arrête le changement
climatique va continuer à exercer sa
presse une pression croissante et
d'autres contraintes environnementales
l'érosion de la biodiversité etc
pour deux raisons la première
l'inertie du système climatique qui fait
que la dérive des 20 prochaines années
est déjà totalement écrite
indépendamment de nos émissions passées
ensuite ce qu'il reste énormément de
charbon a brûlé sur terre et que c'est
pas parce que l'europe va entrer en
récession structurelle à cause du
pétrole que ça va empêcher les chinois
et les indiens plus un certain nombre
d'autres pays à commencer par les états
unis qui peuvent très bien revenir au
charbon une fois qu'ils auront moins de
gaz pas cher de cramer leur charbon
donc l'europe elle est vraiment dans une
situation dans laquelle il est pas du
tout exclu qu'elle est le meilleur des
deux mondes c'est à dire à la fois une
économie en contraction est un
changement climatique qui deviennent
franchement difficile à contrôler à
cause de ce qu'on a déjà émis et de ce
qui continuera à être émis par les
autres donc réponse à la question est ce
qu'on est vraiment dans la merde on
l'est un peu question qui n'a pas été
posée mais est-ce que ça doit tous nous
démoraliser et faire en sorte qu'on
baisse les bras
là j'ai envie de dire non comme disait
une sait plus qui il est trop tard pour
être pessimiste donc au contraire il
faut comprendre qu'on a encore tant
qu'on a des moyens une partie de notre
future entre nos mains c'est difficile
mais il faut y aller alors moi je rêve
c'est une incidence j'ai pas sûr que la
question était posée
je rêve que macron deviennent vraiment
sérieux en ce qui concerne la phrase
qu'il a prononcée sur les scientifiques
la à l'occasion du coc vide alors il
nous a sorti des scientifiques 25 fois
en nous expliquant que maintenant il les
écoute est très bonne nouvelle quand
greta et passez le voir je ne crois pas
qu'il est instantanément vie à ses côtés
un conseil scientifique pour le
conseiller sur l'état des lieux en ce
qui concerne la question climat est
l'état des lieux en ce qui concerne la
question énergétique
il me semble qu'il serait bien avisé de
faire ce genre de choses dare dare et
même sans attendre la fin de la crise
actuelle parce que ça c'est des
questions auxquelles je vais répondre
aussi il est bien évident que si on
tente de faire repartir le système à
l'identique tout ce qu'on prépare c'est
la prochaine crise et quand je dis la
prochaine crise
j'ai envie de dire une crise
supplémentaire alors qu'on sera pas tout
à fait voire pas du tout sorti de
l'actuelle puisqu'on n'a pas vraiment à
faire une crise aujourd'hui on a affaire
à une manifestation supplémentaire
de réaction du système dans un système
qui ne peut pas le propre d'une
situation qui n'est pas durable c'est
que ça dure pas donc en ce moment on est
malheureusement en train d'assister à
une rétroaction du système il y en a eu
avant la civilisation industrielle un
territoire sur du système mais le propre
de toute espèce nombreuses
c'est que les pathogènes arrive à se
transmettre rapidement voilà donc
maintenant qu'on est très très nombreux
les pathogènes arrive à se transmettre
très très facilement alors après nous
allons faire un peu de politique
voilà il ya quelqu'un qui a dit il
paraît que qu'on a les dirigeants qu'il
mérite à quel moyen efficace et
accessible à tous
avant tout pour inciter les dirigeants à
prendre de bonnes décisions en matière
d'énergie et de climat
autrement dit dit l'homme qui fait du
plagiat que devons-nous changer pour
aider aux dirigeants a changé et bien
c'est une excellente question
le j'ai coutume de dire
et alors quand j'en parle en face à face
avec des élus enfin bon quand vous
parler face à face avec des yeux ils
nous disent toujours que vous êtes
quelqu'un formidable dont je me méfie un
peu mais quand j'en parle en face à face
avec des élus ils disent que c'est une
assez bonne au vu de la situation
nos élus sont un très bon reflet de
l'opinion avec toutefois trois ou quatre
ans de décalage
donc c'est la rue c'est la raison pour
laquelle on les aime pas et on a
l'impression que c'est une bande
d'incapables
c'est qu'ils nous ressemblent mais avec
trois ans de décalage donc quand ils
sont en permanence un tout petit peu en
retard par énormément mais un tout petit
peu en retard sur l'état de l'opinion et
du coup ça nous énerve
parce que on a l'impression qu'ils n'ont
pas compris qu'on avait effectivement il
met toujours un peu de temps parce que
il ya une vague londe d'opinion met du
temps à parvenir jusqu alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut qu'on change eh bien j'ai
envie de dire tout ce qu'on peut à
partir du moment où au sein d'une
entreprise l'an
reprise essaye de faire son métier
différemment et où c'est un peu visible
c'est quelque chose qui finit par parler
aux élus à partir du moment où on
consomme un peu différemment et on est
un certain nombre de feurs et bien à ce
moment ça finit par parler aux élus à
partir du moment où on s'exprime
différemment et où on est un certain
nombre à le faire ça finit par parler
aux élus à partir du moment où on a des
actions associatives différentes
ça commence à parler aux élus je crois
savoir que le shift project à une toute
petite part de responsabilité dans la
phrase qui a été prononcée par mâcon là
sur la planification et la sobriété
carbone alors quand je dis une toute
petite part je ne sais pas vous dire si
c'est 1 % ou 90%
mais enfin je pense qu'on en a une toute
petite part donc le second au second
j'ai envie de dire vis-à-vis des élus ce
qu'on peut changer c'est à la fois les
discours et les actes et quand les
discours et les actes change ensemble
c'est là que c'est particulièrement
puissants quand vous avez juste les
discours qui changeait pas les actes à
ce moment du côté de la puissance
publique
il ne se passe pas grand chose alors je
vais prendre un exemple je vous savez on
qui aime bien châtie bien donc j'adore
les financiers qui sont devenus une
partie des clients dont je vais taper
dessus un grand coup dans le monde
financier ces derniers temps ce qui a le
plus augmenté ses les événements pour
dire que le climat c'est important donc
les gens qui gagnent le plus d'argent
dans le monde financier
avec le changement climatique c'est pas
du tout les gens qui essayent de s'en
occuper dans la façon dont on gère les
investissements
c'est les gens qui font des événements
pour dire que cette importante s'en
occuper comme les gens qui sont à
l'intérieur la puissance publique en
l'occurrence le régulateur de
l'intérieur voit très bien qu'il ya un
écart fort entre les discours et les
actes alors là en l'occurrence c'est par
nos dirigeants au sens de nos élus mais
c'est aux régulateurs c'est donc parti
de la puissance publique et bien les
régulateurs ne régule par la finance de
manière différente
ils gardent exactement les règles
d'avant parce qu'ils perçoivent très
très bien le schisme qui lie à entre les
paroles et les actes
à partir du moment où celle inverse
à ce moment la puissance publique peut
sembler un exemple c'est aujourd'hui un
nombre croissant de consommateurs disent
qu'ils sont sensibles au
raccourcissement des chaînes
d'approvisionnement et bien il ya un
certain nombre d'élus
à ce moment qui essaye de réfléchir à ce
genre de choses et qui voit ce qu'on
pourrait commencer à proposer comme
mesure il tenterait de le faire une des
mesures qui permettraient de le faire
est du reste que macron a très
clairement évoqué dans son discours
c'est une forme de préférence nationale
et il est à mon avis probable dans le
pote dans le contexte post qu'ovide
qu'un certain nombre de pays pour donner
la préférence à ce qui se passe chez eux
vont avoir des contrôles des frontières
plus dure et dure est dès à présent
c'est en train de s'appliquer en europe
en europe il ya des frontières intra
européennes qui ont été rétablies je ne
pensais pas voir ça de sitôt
même si quelque part c'était déjà à
l'oeuvre avec le break speed et c'est
pas sûr que ce soit le dernier pays à le
faire avant que je me mets donc il ya un
il ya des sujets comme ça sur lesquels
quand suffisamment de gens se mobilise
de façon visible et bien ça remonte aux
élus
comment est ce que quand on est un
individu concerné on essaye de faire en
sorte que d'autres individus le
deviennent aussi je ne connais que deux
manières de faire il ya essayer de
convaincre par la parole essayer de
convaincre par l'action convaincre par
la rolls par la parole pardon c'est
diffuser de l'information s'est donc
essayé comme je le fais comme d'autres
le font de d'expliquer qu' il faut
essayer de changer l'ordre des priorités
essayer d'être un peu plus précis dans
ce discours que juste dire faut changer
l'ordre des priorités donc dire ben
voilà dans tel domaine ça serait pas
idiot de faire ceci plutôt que cela t1
typiquement dans la relance des travaux
publics ça serait pas idiot de leur
faire construire des pistes cyclables
séparées d'ivoire aux terres plutôt que
de nouvelles voies routières ou de des
ronds-points ou mais pourquoi donc on
peut très bien
comment dire on peut très bien invité à
l'action par son comportement est invité
à l'action par son discours c'est les
deux choses qu'on peut faire
voilà il n'ya pas deux il ya
malheureusement pas de martingale au
sens où c'est des processus qui sont des
processus remontant d'agrégation et qui
sont donc nécessairement lent il faut
faire un groupe croissant de gens qui
pensent à peu près la même chose ou qui
ont envie à peu près de la même chose
qui voit le problème à peu près sous le
même angle
et c'est des choses qui sont lentes à
partir du moment où on veut former un
consensus au sein d'un groupe c il n'ya
pas il ya pas tellement d'autres
manières de faire malheureusement il y
avait un autre un autre une autre
question qui en fait je viens d'y
répondre sur comment faire passer le
message au plus grand nombre
et bien sûr le fait qu' il faut se
préparer à consommer de entre guillemets
meilleure énergie d'en bas alors qu'il
faut pas se préparer à ça mais qu'il
faut se préparer à en consommer moins
bah je le redis par la parole et par
l'action comme on est les animaux
mimétique
l'action est très importante alors la
parole sans l'action j'en ai parlé tout
à l'heure avec mon exemple de la finance
en fait n'a pas beaucoup de porter ce
cas de la porter en général c'est
l'action avec la parole explicative où
la parole et l'action qui sont
cohérentes hilliard dernier point que
j'ai évoquées alors là évidemment le
marché de l'emploi va peut-être un petit
peu un tout petit peu contrarié mais il
ya un point aussi qui fait bouger les
entreprises et donc par ricochet la
puissance publique
c'est la question du choix de l'emploi
pour ceux qui ont le choix
alors il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont peu
ou pas le choix mais il ya aussi des
gens qui ont le choix et quand les gens
exercent ce choix sur l'emploi en ce
temps où est le paramètre carbone climat
décarbonation en sobriété et c est bien
ça finit par remonter je vais vous
donner un exemple que je trouve assez
rigolo et un chef d'entreprise du sud de
la france qui un jour discute avec un
ancien chef d'entreprise qui fait partie
de la garde rapprochée du chiffre et qui
dira tiens l'autre jour il m'est arrivé
un truc absolument extraordinaire
j'avais des entretiens de recrutement
pour quelqu'un de haut niveau un jeune
cadre que je cherchais à recruter tout
se passait très bien et jusqu'au dernier
entretien où le jeune carl me dit est ce
que vous avez un parking à vélo parce
que moi je viens au travail à vélo et
chefs d'entreprises qui recrutent qui
fait par non et odile bas du coup je
viens pas ça c'est typiquement alors
évidemment c'est venait de quelqu'un qui
avait le choix
tout le monde n'est pas capable
d'exercer ce choix mais quand les gens
ont le choix
voilà le voilà le genre de comportement
qui a défait parce que ça fera tellement
que derrière les gens se posent des
questions
[Musique]
alors après il y avait d'autres
questions qui était très lié à ça et
maintenant je vais vous faire un petit
coup de pétrole l'un est ce qu'on risque
pas de votre part l'énergie fossile
repartir de plus belle avec le prix du
baril a alors bonnes nouvelles en europe
je pense que non mais je vais être un
peu plus précis que ça il se trouve que
je vais être un peu plus précis alors
pardon en europe non dans le monde oui
plusieurs éléments de réponse je vais
être un peu discriminés en ce qui
concerne le pétrole
mon sentiment c'est que au moins pour
certain nombre d'années le pic
historique tout pétrole aura été 2008 le
pic historique du pétrole en ce qui
concerne le pétrole conventionnel a été
2008 comme un certain d'entre vous le
savent
c'est une information qui a fini par
être donné dans un rapport de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie publié en
décembre 2018 donc en 2008 tout le
pétrole qui n'est pas du pétrole de
schiste américain et qui n'est pas des
sables bitumineux canadiens est passé
par un maximum et s'est mise à décliner
le l'approvisionnement croissant en
pétrole dans le monde a été le fait de
plusieurs éléments ça dépend qui publie
des statistiques
si vous regardez simplement le pétrole
et les condensats alors ce qu'ils sont
déjà plus prévenant du pétrole
je vais dire après ce que c'est donc les
statistiques publiées par l'energy
information agency des états unis vous
avez un approvisionnement qui a recrues
à partir de 2010
on va dire c'est à dire quand le trait
aux prix du pétrole
inciter tous les foreurs de celle oil et
tous les exploitants de sables
bitumineux du canada à se lancer dans
des exploitations effréné et ça a permis
à l'approvisionnement mondial en liquide
de repartir à la hausse jusqu'en 2018
il ya également eu là dedans un apport
venant du gaz qui s'appelle les
condensats à laon les condensats par des
chaînes carbonées et qui vont de 5
atomes de carbone à 8 atomes de carbone
qu'on appelle parfois des essences
naturelles donc cdc des hydrocarbures
qui sont un peu plus léger que les
essences mais qu' on peut quand même
utilisé pour une partie des applications
du pétrole est rentré dans les
raffineries on va dire en même temps que
le pétrole le la production de cet
ensemble donc accru jusqu'en novembre
et depuis elle a commencé à décroître et
ceci allant avec cela j'ai remarqué en
regardant un certain nombre de
statistiques qu'à un certain nombre de
flux physiques dans le monde avait aussi
commencé soit décroître soit à s'arrêter
de croître depuis cette époque là le
commerce mondial a commencé à s'arrêter
de croître à partir de fin 2010 8 la
production industrielle mondiale a
commencé à hoenheim commencé à décroître
pardon la production industrielle
mondiale s'est arrêtée de croître en
aussi fin 2018 et dans les pays
occidentaux où elle a commencé à
décroître
donc il ya un certain nombre de signes
avant-coureurs que l'approvisionnement
en liquide est vraiment devenu
contraignant depuis fin 2010 8 et depuis
ça avait commencé à décroître
ce qui se passe avec le prix actuel du
baril c'est que le les investissements
dans l'amont pétrolier plonge et en
particulier dans les hydrocarbures de
roche-mère
ouh là vous allez avoir les gens qui
font des trous qui vont très franchement
se calmer or il se trouve que la
production dans les hydrocarbures de
roche mère diminue rapidement une fois
qu'on a arrêté de faire des nouveaux
trous parce que les puits en
exploitation produisent beaucoup pendant
une durée très courte et puis après la
production se casse la figure assez vite
donc ce qui va se passer sur la
production de pétrole avec ce qui se
passe sur le prix du baril en ce moment
c'est que la production va décroître
tant que l'économie s'effondre plus vite
que la production de pétrole
on a à la fois une consommation de
pétrole qui baisse et à prix du baril
qui reste très bas et une production qui
baissent aussi
donc tout ça baisse en même temps à
partir du moment où on essaye de faire
repartir l'économie et donc on profite
de ce pétrole pêcheurs ce qui va se
passer c'est qu'on va se mettre à
tamponner le mur de du pétrole en volume
qui sera un client et à ce moment on va
déclencher un nouveau choc pétrolier
et ça va être ça la limite alors au fait
que les émissions de co2 repartent à la
hausse
le problème est très différent en ce qui
concerne le gaz et le charbon parce que
le gaz la production de gaz est en
hausse
et comme la production de gaz est en
hausse à ce moment là où on utilise du
gaz est bon les solvable pour acheter du
gaz on peut très bien en utiliser plus
et la production de charbons surtout est
essentiellement lié à des utilisations
qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
transports c'est essentiellement de la
production électrique la moitié du
charbon utilisé dans le monde est en
chine et donc en gros si la chine
redémarrent son économie et donc si le
pétrole n'est pas un facteur limitant
pour le redémarrage de l'économie
chinoise ce que je ne sais pas à ce
moment donc si le pétrole est un facteur
limitant pour le redémarrage de
l'économie chinoise et bien même le
charbon ne suivra pas parce que si
l'économie ne redémarre pas par manque
de pétrole du coup elle consomme moins
d'électricité ont fait pas autant
d'électricité
mais si le la restriction sur le pétrole
n'est pas limitantes pour le redémarrage
de l'économie chinoise ou le houleux
l'essor de l'économie maintienne ou d'un
certain nombre d'autres émergents on
peut très bien avoir les émissions de
co2 qui se mettent à repartir de plus
belle
mais ça ne sera pas en lien avec le prix
du pétrole parce que dans ces pays là le
prix du charbon on est
so lu ment pas a servi sur le prix du
pétrole si je regarde le cas de l'europe
l'europe importe tous ces combustibles
donc l'europe importe si j'inclus la
norvège dans l'europe et je vais être un
peu un peu gentil je mets la norvège
dans l'europe
l'europe importe et trois quart de son
pétrole donc on va se retrouver avec un
stress sur le pétrole
l'europe importe aujourd'hui 50% de son
gaz mais là il se trouve que le gaz dans
la mer du nord a passé son pic de 2005
et décline et et comme en europe les
prix du gaz sont pas servis sur les prix
du pétrole aidant les gens gagnent pas
d'argent en vendant du gaz donc avec un
pas prix du gaz oui on a envie d'en
consommer plus mais par contre les
investissements dans l'amont vont se
calmer ya deux eaux
et puis c'est souvent les mêmes
opérateurs donc ils vont supprimer les
capex à la fois dans les investissements
amont à la fois dans le pétrole et le
gaz est enfin en ce qui concerne le
charbon nous sommes passés par le pic de
production du charbon en europe dans les
années 60
et depuis la consommation décline et
elle va continuer à décliner
parce que de toute façon on en a de
moins en moins de deux disponibles
donc je ne pense pas qu'en europe le bas
prix du pétrole va pouvoir relancer
indéfiniment les émissions de co2 parce
qu'on en aura plus à consommer et je
vais rappeler pour finir cette
intervention que depuis que je regarde
le sujet il n'y a pas de lien entre le
prix et le volume 1 ce qui concerne les
autres c'est pas parce que le pétrole
est pas cher que ça veut dire qu'on en a
beaucoup au pour faire beaucoup de co2
et en consomme et enfin pour consommer
beaucoup de pétrole et faire beaucoup de
co2 il faut avoir beaucoup de pétrole et
ben c'est pas parce que le prix est bas
que vous en avez eu beaucoup ces voix là
il n'y a pas de lien entre les deux on
peut très bien en avoir moins qu'avant
avec un prix bas encore une fois il
suffit que l'économie soit suffisamment
déprimé par autre chose que le pétrole
est à ce moment vous avez de moins en
moins de pétrole avec un prix qui peut
rester très bas donc la réponse à cette
question qui est ce que ça ne va pas
repartir de plus belle
donc en europe non et dans le reste du
monde
la réponse est ce qui va être les
émissions qui peuvent repartir de plus
belle ces gaz et charbon parce que
encore une fois le pétrole je pense
qu'on n'est pas loin du maximum pourrait
convoquer aura passé maximum pour
l'instant d'année
et gaz et charbon repartent à la hausse
si le pétrole n'est pas un facteur
limitant sur l'économie des pays qui ont
du charbon je rappelle que neuf pays
dans le monde possèdent plus de 90% du
charbon en termes de réserves
donc le problème est vraiment concentré
sur quelques pays bien d'identifier
c'est pas un problème qui est généralisé
pour l'ensemble de la pour l'ensemble de
la planète
on va tarder à avoir la réponse
par contre là là là alors l'autre
question je sais plus si elle est posée
quelque part qui est est ce que avec ce
qui est en train de se passer on va pas
mettre dans le miroir tous les plans de
relance verte
parce que c'est ça aussi le c'est ça
aussi le danger si on ne met pas dans le
tiroir les plans de relance verte dont
je vois pas la question mais donc je la
prendre quand même mon petit privilège
si on ne met pas dans le tiroir les
plans de relance verte
à ce moment il se peut aussi que dans un
certain nombre de pays les émissions
liées au gaz et charbon ne repartent pas
parce que ces pays font de la relance
entre guillemets verte
donc ça veut dire que en ce qui concerne
le charbon ils relancent pas trop et ils
font plutôt des renouvelables et du
nucléaire
et ça veut dire qu'en ce qui concerne le
gaz il relance pas trop ils font plutôt
autre chose alors ça dépend énormément
parce que le gars est rappelé un truc si
le 6 le si les plans sont mis aux
oubliettes ce qui correspond aujourd'hui
il faut pas se le cacher un à la demande
d'énormément de gens en dix ans
enough is enough c'est bon on a notre
dose à ce moment je le redis ce que
ressources domestiques vont taper dedans
pour autant que la baisse de
l'approvisionnement en pétrole soit pas
limitantes pour leur économie domestique
en question combien faut-il de jours de
confinement par an pour rectifier le tir
climatique
eh bien il faut un covit supplémentaires
par an voilà c'est ça le pour limiter le
réchauffement à 2 degrés d'ici à 2100 il
faut que d'ici à 2050 donc dans les 30
ans qui restent nous ayons diviser nos
émissions par trois et tous ceux d'entre
vous qui ont accès avec celle savent que
les divisions par trois en trente ans ça
fait à peu près mon 4 % par an il se
trouve que -4% sur les émissions c'est à
mon avis l ordre de grandeur de ce qu'on
va avoir cette année alors je vais faire
un petit calcul tout con j'ai fait cet
après midi sur le pétrole
il ya une source qui s'appellera les
stats énergie qui a publié un rapport
qui dit que la consommation de pétrole
cette année va probablement être diminué
de 10% par rapport à une année normale
diminué de 10% par rapport à une année
normale le pétrole qui lui-même
représente 30 % des émissions de co2 de
la planète
ça veut dire que l'on baisse les
émissions de co2 3% à ce titre alors
après si la récession planétaire est
très très méchante et bien on aura aussi
des baisses sur le charbon et le gaz
mais pour le moment les chiffres
préliminaires qui circulent alors qu'ils
sont toujours trop optimiste je vous la
corde met l'inde et la chine en
croissance hors canton à l'inde et la
chine on a
le premier pour sûr et le deuxième ou
troisième de mémoire consommateurs de
charbon dans le monde donc ça veut dire
que c'est très bien que sur le charbon
on ait une stabilité d édition l'année
prochaine
enfin c'est à des pardons et sur le gaz
je ne sais pas donc ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait très bien avoir uniquement
entre guillemets 34 % des émissions de
ges pardon des émissions de co2 cette
année sur terre c'est à dire une année
de baisse qu'il faut avoir tous les ans
donc tous les infos faire -4% par
rapport à l'année précédente pour avoir
les 2 degrés donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut se prendre un qu'ovide
supplémentaires par an tous les ans pour
avoir les 4% de baisse si on ne change
pas l'économie donc là vous comprenez
qu'on les fasse à quelque chose ou c'est
juste les tous les gens qui jusqu'à
maintenant on dit l'europe neutre en
2050 et puis surtout on ne change rien
l'année prochaine c'est des gens qui
sont juste totalement à l'ouest quoi ou
totalement inconscient ce qui est plus
vraisemblable ou des menteurs patentés
ce qu'ils sont probablement un peu aussi
parce que c'est difficile de faire de la
politique sans ça mais enfin mon avis
ils sont juste totalement inconscient
est totalement à l'ouest en ce qui
concerne la compréhension des processus
physiques de seconde et le lien entre
l'énergie et l'économie donc plus si on
veut faire sa manière ordonnée
on a vraiment besoin de passer la
surmultipliée d'accélérer très très
fortement le chi project est en train de
tailler en ce moment alors ça c'est pas
une question qu'on m'a posée à ce que
pourrait être un plan de relance
décarbonés puisque la clown nouvelle de
ce qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment c'est que c'est devenu un peu de
bar sur l'argent donc vous avez tous
compris que l'argent public avait cessé
d'être un problème vous les 100
milliards il ya 100 milliards les deux
sens les deux sens où les 500 il ya 500
et à partir du moment où on est dans un
contexte dans lequel il n'y a qu'à
demander pour avoir les centaines de
milliards
ça veut dire que tous les plans
d'investissements massifs qui suppose
une injection massive d'argent public
pour être réalisé qu'ils s'agissent de
l'énergie qu'il s'agisse du transport
ferroviaire qu'il s'agisse de
transformer le transport routier qu'il
s'agisse de modifier les villes qu'ils
s'agissent des infrastructures pour ce
bn à qu'il s'agisse de l'agriculture
si vous voulez un paquet de centaines de
milliards pour faire des choses
intelligentes on peut discuter
donc on a décidé au shift de lancer
notre propre plan de relance décarbonés
alors c'est une relance pour utiliser un
mot à la mode mais avec tout ce que je
voulais raconter tout à l'heure sur la
récession en fait c'est plutôt un plan
de récession décarbonée
mais ses relances au sens en hausse et
remettre les gens au boulot c'est bien
ça le sait bien ce sujet et c'est ça qui
compte
le pib au fond on s'en fout à partir du
moment où chacun un boulot qui lui paie
à peu près de quoi bouffer et de quoi se
loger et qu'il est content dans la vie
et qu'il a son réseau de relations
sociales qui lui permettent de sentir
bien bon bah fois on peut considérer
qu'on a fait le gros du haut du chemin
donc on se lance dans ce travail qui va
qui va prendre place en plusieurs étapes
la première étape va être de produire
des suggestions de contrepartie pour
tous les gens qui vont demander de
l'aide
vous savez qu'en ce moment un certain
nombre de gens commencent à relire la
soupe est donc en particulier de
transport aérien je parle bien peu plus
tard mais pas que et donc la pomme
question c'est qu'est ce que ces gens là
on peut leur demander comme contrepartie
tout de suite quand vous êtes dans le
grand bain en train de vous voyez le
moniteur qui va vous tendre où le maître
nageur qui attend qu'il avoue tendre la
perche km2 pas vous noyer à ce moment là
il peut vous
demander une promesse que vous ne pouvez
pas refuser parce que sinon ils vont
retenir la perche
eh bien c'est exactement dans ce genre
de réflexion on va se lancer sur les
contreparties donc air france va
demander de sauver qu'est ce qu'on
demande à air france en contrepartie ou
qu'est-ce qu'on impose à air france en
contrepartie en lui disant très bien je
te sauves mais je teins pause ça est ce
que à ce moment là on impose des taxes
d'aéroport est ce qu à ce moment qu'ils
sont proportionnelles à la distance
parcourue
c'est pas qu air france mais ça les
concerne en particulier l'impôt vous eu
un changement accélérée d'avions est ce
qu'on impose la suppression des
premières et des classico des gens
syrien doit réfléchir on va se demander
qu'est ce qu'on peut bien trouver qui
est une mesure qui nous paraît
pertinente pour que air france est une
activité qui demain seront configurés
d'une façon évidente est ce qu'on leur
demande de dire concurrents de la sncf
pour plaire à la sncf est ce que je sais
pas mais en tout cas il faut qu' il faut
que l'on réfléchisse sur qu'est ce qu'on
leur demande et pas une promesse
d'ivrogne pas un truc vous commencez de
celle en six mois un truc ici avec
l'ensemble tout de suite pareil pour les
constructeurs automobiles qui vont venir
dire qu'ils sont très très mal ce qui
est vrai pareil pour le secteur hôtelier
qui va venir dire qu'il est très très
mal
ce qui est vrai mais vous voyez en
france une partie du secteur hôtelier
c'est juste une annexe du transport
aérien est ce qu'il faut laisser ces
gens là dans cet état là où est ce que
finalement tant qu'on les laisse dans
cet état là tout ce qu'on fait c'est
qu'on prépare la prochaine crise est
proche un drame voilà donc on m'a posé
la cervelle sur c'est quoi toutes les
contreparties qu'on peut imaginer
demander tout de suite tu as maintenant
aux gens qu'on va sauver de la noyade
parce que il faut évidemment les sauver
de la noyade parce qu'on va déjà 32 à 4
min chômeurs sur le mois enfin sur ludo
pardon dans l'ex qui est en train de se
passer là et je suis pas ravi pour eux
il faut éviter que ça recommence quoi la
deuxième partie du plan ça va être un
plan d'investissement dans lequel on va
se dire
l'argent n'est plus le sujet donc à
partir du moment où l'argent n'est plus
le sujet on va s'intéresser à tous les
autres facteurs limitant les facteurs
limitants pourrait être la formation par
exemple dans le bâtiment ans pour
augmenter forte dans le nombre de
rénovations à partir du moment où
l'argent n'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est la confiance et la compétence
un certain nombre de gens qui sont
propriétaires dont aucune envie de faire
rénover leurs bâtiments par quelqu'un en
qui ils ont pas confiance
l'isaf est évidemment fier il va faire
des travaux qui serviront à rien il
connaît pas son sujet la confiance va
avec la compétence et la compétence est
un truc qui n'est pas si facile que ça à
augmenter rapidement donc ce qui est
bloquant par exemple dans la rénovation
du bâtiment
c'est pas que l'argent parce que si vous
dites au ménage je fais du hélicoptère
modèle je vous donne un chèque à l'état
vous donne un chat qui vous donne 50
mille balles dépenser le vous comprenez
bien qu'à ce moment le seul sujet c'est
de trouver les gens qui savent faire
d'être sûr qu'ils vont bien faire d'être
sûr du résultat et c'est donc là c'est
typiquement sur ce sujet là qu'il est
important de travailler et si on veut
avoir 200 300 400 vie d'artisan
supplémentaires dans le bâtiment parce
que c'est à peu près ce qu'il faut si on
peut relever de manière pertinente un
million que je m'en parle voilà un
exemple c'est sur le bâtiment
je pourrais en prendre pleins d'autres
qu'est ce que je demande aux
constructeurs automobiles il est sauvé
ce que je leur dis va très bien je vous
souvenez vous allez mettre 4 milliards
sur la table et me faire une usine de
batteries en france askaf voilà le jeu
là je suis en train de vivre par des
secrets parce que c'est des idées
auxquelles certains déjà pensé on va
essayer de mettre tout ça en ordre et de
réfléchir derrière investissements
structurants et formation en déplacement
d'emplois et puis on va également
essayer de réfléchir à un certain nombre
de modifications de règles fiscales
parce qu'à partir du moment où les
centaines de milliards se balade dans
tous les sens on peut en profiter pour
faire un peu de toilettage fiscale
et même beaucoup de toilettage fiscales
et réglementaires que l'on mettrait en
oeuvre cette occasion voilà donc on va
se lancer dans c dans ses manoeuvres la
halle à ce chiffre
c'est à dire qu'on va essayer de faire
des choses pratiques par pas de la
pétition de principe alors c'est très
très bien inquiets de la pétition de
principe
dit autrement que ya des tas de gens à
d'état d'instance qui disent c'est
important de ne pas oublier la
décarbonation où c'est important que la
décarbonation sur le fer de lance du
plan de relance
ça s'est il ya plein de gens pour le
dire c'est parfait c'est très bien on en
a besoin de chiffres les premiers par
contre tant que c'est juste faut pas
oublier que c'est une façon de dire
messieurs du gouvernement on pense que
vous avez en interne des ressources pour
concevoir le plan dans lequel il ya à la
fois les gens retourne bosser et la
décarbonation est incluse dans le plan
et alors là le petit père jancovici dit
non donc ils ont pas du tout les
compétences pour faire ça ils ont pas du
tout le logiciel pour faire ça il n'y
ont jamais pensé ils seront un foutu de
faire le moindre pot qui flotte dans ce
genre de dans ce genre de contexte ayant
et a fortiori dans l'urgence quand on
voit que la france est même pas foutu
d'avoir une politique énergétique qui
soit cohérente avec le problème à
traiter je pars de la décarbonation faut
pas espérer une seconde qu'un monde
politique tétanisés et un monde aux
fonctionnaires qui se sont auto tension
euros sont ceinturés pardon pendant des
années vont être capable d'accoucher à
la volée de quelque chose qui est le
plan du grand tout même si notre ami
macron avait des accents très gaullien
dans son dernier discours et qu'il a
nommément cité le programme du conseil
national de la résistance qui s'appelait
les gens heureux
donc le il n'y a pas du tout la
compétence donc
donc quand on dit le chiffre project à
s'y attaquer c'est pas parce qu'on est
des prétentieux un truc c'est parce
qu'on pense que juste d'ailleurs le
reboisement
c'est le grand vide parce que il n'y a
pas eu de travaux préexistence sur ce
genre de sujet ce que ça deviendra ces
propositions donc ça sera rendu public
et portait bien évidemment la partie
contre partie on espère d'ici un mois un
mois et demi et la partie investissement
on va dire d'ici à l'été et je le redis
on va essayer de ne pas refaire ce qui
existe déjà
c'est à dire il faut mettre des
milliards etc mais d'être beaucoup plus
précis dans la location et dans les
mesures et dans l'arbitrage et
éventuellement dans les trucs qu'il faut
arrêter petits chiffres que je vous
livre parce que j'ai fait le calcul
l'autre jour vous connaissez ma grande
marotte sur les nerfs vous savez
également pour un certain nombre d'entre
vous que aujourd'hui le contribuable
afin de vie de 18 à payer ou payera 100
milliards d'euros pour les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires qui sont soient
construits soit autorisé à construire à
fin 2010 8 et bien 120 milliards d'euros
avec cet argent on aurait pu doubler la
totalité du réseau routier français je
dis bien la totalité du réseau routier
français d'un réseau de pistes cyclables
le réseau routier français fait un
million de kilomètres pour faire une
piste cyclable c'est à peu près cent
mille euros du kilomètre en bande
séparer ces trois cent mille en piste
autonome et 100 et 80 villes en bancs de
séparer alors je vous fais une cote mal
taillée allez on va dire six ans et même
si c'était 150
ça veut dire que les deux tiers du
réseau routier français pourrait être
doublée en piste cyclable je dis bien
les deux tiers donc en gros on pourrait
en piste sécurisée circuler partout en
france
le bout en bout de n'importe où on
pourrait aller de lille à perpignan en
vélo envoi sécurisé en travers sur
toutes les villes si on voulait
envoi sécurisé avec l'argent qu'on a mis
dans les éoliennes et les panneaux
solaires
donc on va mettre donc il ya un peu de
tri à faire aussi dans ce qu'on est en
train de faire en ce moment aujourd'hui
on poursuit des programmes qu'on empile
les uns sur les autres parce que pour
revenir au début de cette intervention
on pense qu'on sera toujours en
croissance et donc un problème nouveau
moyen de gros et c'est pas la peine de
trier dans ce qu'on faisait avant la
réponse est que si malheureusement on va
être obligé de trier et donc on va être
obligé de parer au plus pressé de
remettre les problèmes dans l'ordre
c'est probablement le plus difficile
dans ce genre de programme de relance
décarbonée parce que c'est très très
difficile de faire changer les gens de
discours d'habitude et comment dire et
de croyance partagée avec leur entourage
parce que vous savez quand vous avez un
discours vous finissez pas rassembler
autour de vous des gens qui vous
ressemble je n'y fais pas du tout
exception si demain matin
ma conviction profonde devait être que
le changement climatique on s'en fout et
bien le premier problème que ça me
poserai c'est que ça me couperais
instantanément d'une bonne partie de la
totalité de mes relations
professionnelles ou à peu près et d'une
bonne partie de mes relations
personnelles donc le
le discours qui ont changé de discours
et changer l'ordre des priorités il faut
bien comprendre que c'est douloureux
pour la majeure partie des êtres humains
faibles que nous sommes et c'est une des
grandes difficultés à mon avis du
portage de ce genre de plan donc bien le
concevoir et essayer de faire des choses
qui n'ont pas l'air complètement stupide
c'est quelque chose que ça ou je pense
qu'on arrivera à faire
par contre à voir là la capacité et la
psychologie pour qu' un certain nombre
de gens en face accepte de se rallier à
ce point de vue sera probablement la
partie la plus difficile du chemin à
n'en pas douter si vous voulez être tenu
au courant de cette affaire là il
suffira d'aller sur le site du chiffre
project et de s'inscrire sur la
newsletter
parce que bien évidemment on diffusera
dès on diffusera des informations sur le
sur la question alors je pense que j ai
pas répondu et aujourd'hui je faire un
exploit je ne vais pas prendre une
question sur le nucléaire pas une seule
les particuliers à question alors j'ai
déjà peu répandu tout à l'heure mais est
ce que l'état où les banques peuvent
réquisitionner tout ou partie des et par
des particuliers afin de soutenir
l'économie ou la finance alors la
réponse est non c'est pas utile c'est
pas utile alors parce que les banques
font de natation dans des tailleurs à
chaque fois que les banques accordent un
crédit alors c'est un peu compliqué de
rentrer dans les détails donc je vais
pas le faire
mais rené la conclusion c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'une banque commerciale
accorde un crédit et c'est justement
pour ça que les établissements bancaires
ont des licences spéciale elle fait de
la création monétaire
le la vraie difficulté pour une banque
ce qu'il avait vraiment en difficulté
c'est si un instant donné
la totalité des gens qui possèdent des
comptes bancaires enfin des gens et des
entreprises réclament au même moment de
disposer cet argent sous forme de cet
argent sous forme liquide
donc si demain matin la totalité des
gens qui dans ce pays ont des comptes de
particuliers se précipita la banque en
disant j'ai dix mille euros sur mon
compte 5000 50100 lilou pour les
entreprises
et je voudrais avoir ça sous forme de
billets donnez le moi est bien là les
banques sont incapables de répondre à
cette demande donc si elles le font
elles font faillite alors fois
exactement si on se retrouve dans ce
genre de situation elles font faillite
par contre tant qu'on n'est pas dans ce
genre de situation et qu'il s'agit juste
d' avoir de la ressource est bien là le
problème n'existe pas parce qu'elles
sont refinancées par la banque centrale
la banque centrale elle-même créé de la
mode est alors nous on a un petit sujet
dans la zone euro c'est que la banque
centrale ait pas dans les pays elle est
commune à la zone euro alors ça par
contre ça peut poser des problèmes mais
qui ne sont pas des problèmes de
réquisition de l'épargné des
particuliers qui sont d'autres problèmes
mais le met la réquisition de l'épargné
populaire et non ça j'y crois pas par
contre ce qui peut se passer c'est que
les par des particuliers le perdre de la
valeur à cause de ce que j'expliquais
tout à l'heure qui est que vous pouvez
avoir des taux négatifs qui s'installe
une érosion alors une bonne manière pour
une banque de faire des taux négatifs
sur les dépôts des particuliers c'est
taxer les comptes donc votre argent vous
rapporte rien et le compte quelque chose
dans une forme de ton négatif alors
pompe aux mains
ploum ploum 1 à agriculture ben voilà on
va parler d'agriculture ça c'est sympa
de l'aviculture
au vu de la petite heure actuelle
l'avenir et la résilience sont à
chercher dans de petites agglomérations
que la région parisienne projetez-vous
de délocaliser les locaux de carbone
capté du shift project à cahors ou à
vitré répondre à ces deux questions et
le télétravail massif qui s'impose en ce
moment les six lancements la possibilité
à des boîtes de services de se
délocaliser dans les petites villas je
pense que c'est une excellente question
est en fait
alors d'abord il se trouve que carbone 4
a aujourd'hui un deux trois quatre cinq
[Musique]
quasiment 10% de ses effectifs en
télétravail en province donc on pourra
contrats de bureaux en province on va en
avoir on va ouvrir une antenne à lyon où
là on aura des bureaux à partir de la
rentrée
mais par contre enfin sauf si le monde
c'est tellement effondré qu'on est
mobilisé pour les faire la guerre mais
sinon non
par contre le nous nous avons déjà donc
lutter travaillent deux chiffres dans le
shift n'a pas de télétravail j'ai envie
de dire avec des gens qui sont postés en
province en permanence par contre que ce
soit un carbone 4 ou au shift on a des
gens qui télétravaillent depuis la
province de temps en temps ça c'est des
choses qui se passent
il se trouve que le métier de 44 est un
métier dans lequel avant la crise du coc
vide les gens et mais quand même bien se
voir le métier du conseil et par métier
de confiance
un consultant en général c'est quelqu'un
à qui vous posez une question parce que
vous faites confiance pour la réponse et
le métier de confiance et un métier on
est des animaux on est comme ça qui fait
que de temps en temps vous avez bien
avoir les gens en face de vous vraiment
parce que il faut détecter le langage le
langage du visage favola il ya des
choses qui même même derrière un écran
sont pas toujours faciles à pas toujours
facile à percevoir
là par exemple vous voyez ma trombine
voyez pas ce que je fais avec mes mains
voyez pas si j'ai les mains terriblement
crispé parce que je suis nerveux si je
suis en train de me gratter les fesses
si je suis par ailleurs en train
d'écrire un billet donc je sais pas quoi
vous voyez pas donc vous voyez bien on
est à distance
on a presque l'impression d'être face à
face mais pas complètement totalement il
manque un petit quelque chose par
rapport à si on était dans la même pièce
donc dans le métier du conseil on aime
bien de temps en temps être dans la même
pièce que les gens qu'on a en face de
soi et donc c'est un métier et par
ailleurs c'est un métier dans lequel le
client considère que c'est plutôt à vous
de venir chez lui que à lui de venir
chez vous de ce fait comme les sièges
sociaux sont essentiellement à paris
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'écosystème des sièges sociaux un
consultant donc c'est compliqué d'avoir
une délocalisation totale
de nos activités en province par contre
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que ça
correspond à une aspiration d'une bonne
partie des gens qui travaillent chez
nous alors pas nécessairement de
s'installer en province mais d'avoir la
possibilité d'être plus souvent en
dehors de paris ça oui et c'est une
aspiration qui est probalement partagée
par une bonne partie des gens qui se
disent que les villes c'est pas
nécessairement l'endroit où il fera le
meilleur traîner dans un parent à dire
de moyen et de long terme est par
ailleurs il ya un autre un autre sujet
qui se pose pour plein de jeunes qui est
le coût d'accès au logement et à partir
du moment où vous travaillez depuis
cahors pour reprendre cet exemple il est
évident que avec le même salaire payé
par votre boîte parisienne
et bien vous n'avez pas exactement les
mêmes conditions de vie
quand vous êtes à cahors et quand vous
êtes à paris accès à un logement plus
grand votre pouvoir d'achat au bon soin
en pratique donc le donc la voilà donc
le fait qu'on est des plus gros à paris
tente les sièges sociaux resteront à
paris c'est peu probable que ça change
de façon radicale par contre après la
crise du coc vide lié du télétravail et
notamment et la visioconférence qui
s'installe comme étant des pratiques
ordinaires à ce moment si c'est le cas
il est à peu près évident que ça offrira
une plus grande souplesse à des gens qui
font un métier comme le nôtre
pour aller où s'installer ou
s'installer plus fréquemment on va dire
en province mais tout le monde n'est pas
dans le cas de 44 donc il ya beaucoup de
gens qui ne peuvent pas télétravail et
de façon non durables parce que quand
vous êtes fleuriste garde d'enfants ou
même vendeur en grande surface c'est
quand même un peu compliqué de
télétravail et donc tous les métiers ne
s'y prête pas nécessairement mais c'est
sûr qu'il va y avoir une augmentation du
télétravail moi je le pense après ce
qu'on est en train de vivre le
télétravail qui va je crois à prendre le
plus d'importance c'est pas tant les
gens qui vont passer d'une grande ville
une petite ville après je répondrais sur
l'aménagement du territoire largement
mais pas t'en passer d'une grande ville
à une petite ville que de gens qui vont
continuer à vivre là où ils vivent
simplement ils iront au bureau quatre
jours par semaine ou trois jours et demi
par semaine au lieu d'y aller cinq jours
par semaine parce qu'il se dire on voit
de temps en temps je suis pas plus mal à
être en pantoufles et à m'éviter le
déplacement et à avoir le temps d'aller
faire un peu de sport à côté de chez moi
ou d'aller me balader au jeu pourquoi
parce qu'à ce moment là on sera des
confiné et qu'on pourra aller se balader
voilà je trouve que c'est globalement
pas désagréable à titre personnel c'est
une organisation que j'ai très longtemps
pratiqué quand j'avais des jeunes
enfants parce que je voulais absolument
rester avec eux le mercredi et donc il y
avait un jour dans la semaine où j'étais
chez moi pendant très longtemps j'ai
fait ça donc le donc le télétravail ne
modifie pas pendant là où je voulais en
dire c'est que le télétravail ne modifie
pas nécessairement la répartition
spatiale des habitations pour que la
répartition spatiale des habitations se
modifient durablement il faut que les
activités se modifient durablement alors
exemples d'activités qui se modifierait
durablement qui fait carbone cap
pourrait recruter des tas de gens en
province c'est que la première pme venu
et l'obligation de tenir une double
compte avec à la fois la comptable des
terres
contat carbone et que cette contact
carbone soit pour une bonne partie
d'entre elles externalisés voilà si
c'était ça qui se passait à ce moment
c'est évident qu'on pourrait avoir de
l'activité y compris à cahors mais pour
le moment il n'y a pas de sièges sociaux
à cahors qui nous demande notre avis il
n'y a pas de clients du to a qu'à voir
qui nous demande notre avis pour le mans
il s'en passe très bien
pas qu'ils aient raison c'est comme ça
donc on ne peut pas envoyer de genre à
cahors pour y rester à demeure on a un
salariés en télétravail à toulouse
depuis très très longtemps et bien même
à toulouse qui est pourtant un gros
bassin d'activité d'emploi etc
alors bon l'aéronautique aime pas trop
de carbone eh bien on a du mal
si l'aéronautique avait beaucoup de
carbone je pense qu'il aurait de quoi
s'occuper totalement localement et bien
mais dans l'aéronautique n'aimons pas
beaucoup le carbone l'âme à toulouse il
a du mal à s'occuper beaucoup de façon
locale c'est pas simple donc le puisque
pas énormément de gens qui demandent qui
nous demandent des choses donc le la
possibilité encore une fois de d'éclater
les structures dépend énormément de la
possibilité d'éclater les activités
alors ce qui est sûr maintenant si je
réponds à la question beaucoup plus
général et pas juste à 44 ce qui est sûr
c'est que dans un monde qui va se
retrouver contrainte sur l'énergie on va
se retrouver globalement contre un sur
les flux et en particulier les flux
longues distances à partir du moment où
on est contraint sur les flux longue
distance on a un problème arithmétique
qui est qu'on n'arrive plus à nourrir
les villes parce que quand vous en
passer des millions de personnes au même
endroit eh bien vous ne pouvez pas
nourrir ces gens là sans faire venir la
nourriture de loin dans la dans la
proximité immédiate de la ville vous
n'avez pas la possibilité c'est
géométriques cette affaire là vous
n'avez pas la possibilité de d'augmenter
de façon pendant que vous avez pas la
possibilité de courir de façon
significative les gens avec un
approvisionnement raisonnablement locale
si vous voulez faire ça c'est encore une
fois c'est la géométrie de base il faut
faire décroître la taille des villes
alors le problème c'est que c'est pas du
tout ça qu'on est enfin faire en ce
moment par exemple le projet du grand
paris est un projet de croissance de
l'airé urbaine parisienne c'est donc un
projet stupide objectivement
anachronique
c'est un projet qui à 50 ans 60 ans le
grand paris je crois que les premières à
la première fois qu'il ya eu cette envie
de faire un grand paris c'était dans les
années 60 et du reste l'urbanisation du
plateau de saclay j'en sais quelque
chose puisque j'ai passé quelques années
c'est cesser les années la fin des
années 60 le début des années 70 l'école
polytechnique quand elle a déménagé sur
le plateau c'était le début d'un point
d'un plan qui a toujours été de faire le
grand paris
à cet endroit là donc c'est un projet
très ancien donc ces projets très
anciens sont malheureusement aujourd'hui
des projets totalement anachronique
parce que il faut faire dégonfler les
grandes métropoles et non pas les faire
gonfler il faut faire les bons choix il
le fallait faire dégonfler parce qu'on
aura pas de quoi les nourrir
dans un monde très contraint sur
l'énergie et l'agriculture urbaine il
suffira pas c'est pas parce que vous
allez avoir quelques fermes de fraises
hydroponique loger dans quelques tours
que vous allez réussir à nourrir 10
millions de franciliens qui tous les
jours ont besoin de manger des choses
autre chose que des fraises et ce même
si on diminue significativement la
quantité de viande comment je veux dire
eux mêmes en divisant par 3 ou 4 la
quantité de viande qu'on mange
il n'en reste pas moins que tout le
monde ne deviendra pas végétarien sans
contrainte à la suppression totale des
animaux d'élevage sont face que la
viande viennent interdite
franchement a guère dit vous aurez
j'avais 12 ans et moins
ça c'est clair et par ailleurs il ya un
vrai sujet et les agronomes disent que
de supprimer des animaux d'élevage qui
font des amendements qui fertilisent
c'est pas nécessairement une bonne idée
la bouse de vache c'est le premier
fertilisants pour vous avez pas d'andré
donc
et à l'époque où il y avait des animaux
de trait et il n'y avait pas d'engrais
de synthèse ski fertiliser les champs
c'était lesquin des chevaux de trait et
des buzz de trait donc la suppression
totale du cheptel n'est pas
nécessairement quelque chose qui est
pertinent quand on veut une agriculture
durable
il ya un équilibre à trouver mais pour
en revenir à ce que 10 mm avec beaucoup
moins de viande
vous avez quand même une production
agricole qui est nécessaire pour donner
les grandes villes à commencer par paris
et ou plus exactement l'ile-de-france
qui nécessitent des transport longue
distance et quand vous avez plus les
transport longue-distance abonnant vous
avez un problème
et comme nourrir et quand même reste
quelque chose qui se mangeait pas se
nourrir ou manger est quelque chose qui
reste nécessaire
très très court terme on va dire eh bien
ça va évidemment conditionné la taille
des villes
ça va aussi conditionné leur pertinence
économique parce que une ville vidée
change et donc dans un monstre contre un
sur les flux la pertinence économique
d'avoir une grosse ville va baisser et
donc vous avez une partie de la ville
qui deviendra sans sans objet sans
utilité dans ce monde là ça sent un
réservoir un sourire des autres une fois
que j'ai dit ça je n'ai traité qu'à
moitié du problème parce que l'autre
moitié du problème c'est d'abord où on
l'aimait par rapport à la france d'antan
où il y avait 40 millions de personnes
aujourd'hui on est quasiment 70 donc
est-ce qu'il ya assez d'espacé ailleurs
on met les gens partout on peut
probablement qu'avant d'en arriver à la
densité d'habitation de l'inde ont
encore un peu de marge mais probablement
que la réponse est oui mais voilà et
puis la deuxième question encore plus
important c'est comment on fait pour
qu'ils y aillent alors la sarre boucle
avec la question de l'emploi que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure une bonne il faut
réfléchir à la façon dont les gens où
ils allaient peut-être que par exemple
ce qui vient d'être fait en ce moment
avec un grand appel à ce que des
français il ya des agriculteurs pour
s'occuper des récoltes peut-être qu'on
pourrait à chaud il a tout de suite fixé
une partie de ces gens là de façon
pérenne parce que c'est des chômeurs
parce que c'est des gens qui ont envie
de changer d'emploi parce que j'ai pas
quoi
en leur offrant très très vite un
logement et un revenu pérenne
peut-être que c'est une bonne manière de
commencer les d'initié de mouvement donc
il va falloir être à la fois
opportuniste il va également falloir
avoir des mesures d'accompagnement par
exemple si on veut faire diminuer les
airs urbaine ça veut dire qu'une partie
des pavillons vont devoir être retourné
au gazon ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
créer des fonds d'indemnisation pour les
gens dont on va détruire les habitations
pour refaire des cultures derrière parce
que je boucle sur ce que je disais tout
à l'heure
et comme personne n'a pensé le monde en
contraction jusqu'à maintenant ce que je
dis peut avoir l'air totalement
iconoclaste [ __ ] c'est que beaucoup de
choses sont à inventer pour l'excellente
raison que pour le moment c'est un cadre
de réflexion qui était étranger ou un
cadre exactement qui était étranger à la
réflexion de tous les gens qui se
demandaient comment organiser la société
toulon qui se sont posé cette question
se sont tous posé la question dans un
univers en expansion dans lequel il
était facile de faire croître la taille
des villes et différemment j'ai tout le
monde et d'y faire consommer tout le
monde donc il va falloir être inventifs
le travail commence maintenant j'ai
envie de dire on a décidé là aussi aux
chiffres project de s'attaquer à la
question
à petite vitesse avec nos faibles moyens
mais c'est une question qui à mon avis
est absolument cruciale en termes
d'aménagement du territoire
on va évidemment avoir un problème
d'impression aussi pour ce genre de
choses parce que c'est des évolutions
qui sont lentes
quand vous mettez tous les gens des
villes à la campagne en quelques années
ça s'appelle une déportation ça
s'appelle pas eu d'évolution
les quelques pays qui se sont risqués à
faire ce genre de truc en général
l'ambiance était moyen sympa donc je
suis pas sûr qu'on ait très envie de ça
et si on veut gérer ça un rythme qui
soit j'ai envie de dire compatible avec
la stabilité sociale
ça veut dire que ça doit être maintenue
sur des décennies voire le siècle et
donc ça doit transcender les alternances
politiques et on sait bien que dans
notre pays le long terme a trop souvent
tendance à les gérer à la petite semaine
de la démagogie du moment donc c'est
pour transcender les alternances
politiques
il n'y a pas de 153 manière de faire ça
nous ramène aussi un point précédent de
la discussion il faut créer des
consensus très fort dans la population
et à ce moment
quelle que soit la personne au pouvoir
comme le consensus est très fort on ne
touche pas à quelque chose qui fait
totalement consensus par exemple
aujourd'hui il fait totalement consensus
quelle que soit la façon enfin quelles
que soient les considérations qu'on a
sur le fait que ce soit bien ou mal géré
et qu'il faut des hôpitaux donc vous
n'aurez jamais le moindre candidat qui
va proposer de supprimer les hôpitaux
voilà ça n'existera jamais parce que
c'est tout le monde est d'accord sur le
fait il en faut après vous pouvez ne pas
être d'accord sur ce qu'il faut leur
donner plus d'argent en moins d'argent
traiter d'abord les jeunes traiter
d'abord les vieux les scellés ou pas me
laisser mourir ou pas mourir les gens
qui sont en fin de vie etc tout ça on
peut discuter mais en attendant ils font
des hôpitaux
voilà c'est exactement pareil il faut
faire émerger le consensus sur le fait
qu'il faut faire dégonfler les villes et
donc on est renvoyé à nouveau auprès de
précédents ou un prologue précédent qui
et comment faire émerger ce consensus
dans la population malheureusement c'est
un travail lent et patient qui demande
que très souvent on remettre le métier
ouvrage sur le métier pardon parce que
c'est la population a aussi été
biberonné à des propositions qui ont été
forgés dans un monde en croissance et
donc c'est des propositions qui seront
nécessairement surprenant dérangeant
déroutante iconoclastes pour beaucoup
même si une partie de la population est
probablement prête aussi
vous ne savez peut-être pas mais il ya
un sondage qui a été publié il ya
maintenant quelques années qui montrait
que les deux tiers des franciliens
aspirer à quitter l'île de france donc
une partie de la population est
peut-être plus prête que l'idée qu'on
s'en fait alors part par contre c'est
pas du tout sûr que les deux tiers des
franciliens soient prêts à aller occuper
autre chose qu'un emploi qui ressemble à
celui qu'ils ont ailleurs donc là il
faut à la fois à changer le lieu où les
gens habitent échanger l'activité qu'ils
ont puisque dans un monde à l'énergie
contraintes tout le monde ne travaillera
pas dans un bureau un sujet que c'est un
sujet vous connaissez probablement pas
ce que je dis et je répète ça dans les
conférences dans un monde à l'énergie
contrainte
heureusement ou malheureusement selon
les points de vue on aura des activités
qui seront moins assis sur un fauteuil
comme en ce moment est un peu plus où on
devra faire des choses avec nomade
novembre donc il faut faire deux montées
de marches à la fois qui est à la fois
changé de lieu et changer d'activité
mais enfin il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui arrivent donc à partir du
moment où tout ça est bien encadré en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que si on
s'en occupe pas il se passera rien ou en
tout cas pas de façon ordonnée donc
c'est très désagréable
il vaut mieux s'en occuper de façon de
façon constructive
après il ya un sujet à un sujet d'europe
parler d'europe c'est intéressant le
mans quel modèle agricole européen dans
le monde de demain
est-ce qu'il faut pas remettre des gens
dans les champs
réponse oui je viens de dire il faut
remettre les gens dans les champs sauf
que dans les champs au lieu d'être
confortablement assis sur un fauteuil
comme moi même si au bout de deux heures
je vais avoir envie de me lever vous
êtes le dos cassé en deux parce que la
terre est basse que voilà donc il faut
en avoir envie
c'est pas nécessairement très simple il
ya des gens qui peuvent en avoir envie
artistes mais voilà c'est pas quelque
chose qui se fait en un en un claquement
de doigts il faut remettre si on veut
remettre plus de genre dans les champs
il faut également y remettre une
fraction croissante de la valeur ajoutée
donc ça veut dire que
les dépenses des ménages il faut
accepter l'idée que la nourriture var
coûter plus cher
si vous voulez que les gens soient plus
tôt dans les champs et pas dans les
villes ça veut dire que entre le
producteur et le consommateur il faut
essayer de supprimer des intermédiaires
alors qu'est ce que vous avez comme
intermédiaire est à dire sur la
distribution table que vous détruisez
les emplois dans la distribution
vous payez les gens - vous allez
détruire des emplois et vous avez
également le transport
un camion sur trois dans ce pays
transporte quelque chose qui se mange du
reste j'ai appris il ya pas longtemps
que trafic actuellement sur autoroute en
matière de poids lourds c'était à peu
près 40% du trafic normal avec un camion
sur trois qui se transportent des trucs
qui se mange plus les autres camions qui
transportent des masques pour hôpitaux
et des baskets et j'ai de quoi enfin un
truc que vous avez commandé sur amazon
enfin ou sur leurs concurrents voilà on
doit y être à peu près mais donc le donc
le transport routier va souffrir
s'il ya un intermédiaire parce que c'est
que vous allez acheter aux producteurs
du coin n'y a pas de transport routier
les fabricants d'emballages vont
souffrir donc je retombe sur la sobriété
tout à l'heure qui récessive donc il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui sont out
of business et il faut se poser la
question de savoir ce qu'on fait avec
ces gens là alors une solution
s'agissait de dire m'a très bien les
transporteurs routiers vont devenir
agriculteur ou employés de l'agriculture
dit comme ça oui
est-ce qu'ils sont d'accord voilà est-ce
que ça va être facile de les former pour
sarah voilà voilà donc c'est vous voyez
bien la façon la plus simple de gérer ça
c'est avec les départs naturels
c'est à ce rythme là que c'est simple de
gérer tous les gens qui partent à la
retraite dans le transport routier tous
les ans voulait remplacer pas et à la
place de sarah où la société se
débrouille pour embaucher des gens qui
sont salariés dans le monde à l'école si
vous voulez que les gens il ya il faut
que ce soit à peu près correctement
payés par rapport aux alternatives
qu'ils ont donc même si les intérêts
même si globalement les revenus baissent
tant que les emplois dans le monde
agricole sont mal payés par rapport aux
alternatives qui sont physiquement moins
dur c'est compliqué d'y aller si on veut
que ce soit bien payé à ce moment il
faut se poser la question de savoir
comment est ce que la collectivité aide
et alors il m'est venu par exemple une
idée farfelue il ya deux jours donc je
vous la livre parce qu'elle est farfelu
j'aime bien l'idée farfelue
on pourrait très bien imaginer dans
l'agriculture exactement le même
mécanisme de prix garantis que celui
qu'on a dans l'électricité d'origine
renouvelable et qui abondent
il serait beaucoup plus intéressant dans
l'agriculture c'est que tous les
agriculteurs qui s'engagent à respecter
un cahier des charges en terme de
densité d'emplois par hectare en termes
de pratiques culturales bio
agroforesterie etc
en termes de recours aux intrants en
termes d'émissions de co2 ou leur
garantit des prix minimum pour les
produits qui sortent de leur
exploitation à partir du moment où le
prix de marché est au dessus du prix
minimum
tant mieux pour eux ça veut dire qu'il
empoche le prix de marché et si le prix
de marché et en dessous du prix minimum
est bien la collectivité compense la
différence donc nos impôts payent des
gens qui produisent de façon entre
guillemets propres et pertinente
vous avez des manières de faire monter
la valeur des productions aujourd'hui
qui ressemble à ça par exemple le lait
qui sert à faire du comté est un lait
qui est beaucoup mieux payés que le lait
qui sert que vous retrouvez en premier
prix dans les grandes surfaces
en face d'eux parce que vous avez une
appellation d'origine qui protège donc
en gros c'est du protectionnisme qui
permet de vendre le produit plus cher
donc là en l'occurrence le prix garanti
il est fourni par l'appellation
d'origine
c'est une façon de fournir des prix
garantis et les producteurs en face de
ça on peut leur faire respecter un
cahier des charges qui est que leurs
vaches sont au pâturage mange du foin
sont pas shooté aux hormones et c'est
qu'ils utilisent le certaines races que
voilà qu'ils ont ils ont un élevage
extensif avec des pratiques qui sont
plus soutenables que d'autres et on
pourrait très bien imaginer qu'on
généralise ce système donc vaut mon idée
totalement farfelue encore une fois
d'être complètement irréaliste alors ce
qui est sûr c'est que une idée de cette
nature ne peut pas s'appliquer
aujourd'hui dans un cadre européen
parce que les règles européennes ne le
permettent pas et donc je reviendrai un
peu plus tard sur le détricotage de
certaines règles européennes qui me
paraît aujourd'hui être un vrai vrai
problème source de quelques inquiétudes
et de quelques nuits blanches qu'il
dormait mal ce qui n'est pas le cas ça
ça me paraît être un passionné
le fait de faire revenir du monde dans
l'agriculture je le redis pour moi il
n'ya pas deux cent cinquante trois
manières
faut faire revenir une part croissante
de la valeur ajoutée là dedans et donc
une part croissante de la dépense des
ménages est derrière organisés les
transferts d'emplois donc on en revient
à ce que j'étais tout à l'heure des
secteurs qui perdent vers ce secteur qui
doit gagner
et effectivement à partir du moment où
vous faites revenir du monde dans
l'agriculture derrière vous allez vous
allez revitaliser les campagnes parce
que vous ferez revenir du monde dans les
services les écoles se sont vidés parce
que l'agriculture s'est vidé un et c'est
que tout le monde connaît la déprise ran
partir du moment où vous faites de la
reprise ou orales bas tout le reste on
gros va spontanément repartir dans
l'autre sens et vous aurez plus de
médecins et plus d'instituteurs parce
qu'il y aura plus de gens à soigner et
plus de gamins à qui il faut fermer
place le problème à ce joli plan c'est
la question européenne parce
qu'aujourd'hui comme vous le savez on a
mis en commun une ressource essentielle
au moment où on a fait l'europe qui est
la question agricole
alors pourquoi est ce qu'on l'a mis en
commun pas parce qu'on voulait regarder
les agriculteurs parce que je vous
rappelle que l'europe c'est la mise en
commun de ressources essentielles pour
pas se mettre sur la gueule
c'était ça le projet européen donc le
projet européen c'était d'abord de
mettre en commun le charbon et l'acier
qui a été une cause historique de guerre
qui ont laissé quelques petites traces
entre les pays qui étaient de part et
d'autre de l'alsace la lorraine et la
ruhr s'est quand même bien mis sur la
gueule pour ça et puis derrière
par extension on a mis en commun
l'énergie c'était euratom et puis au
moment où on a fait l'union européenne à
des premiers trucs qu'on a mis en commun
c'est l'agriculture parce que c'était
absolument indispensable de retrouver
une capacité agricole et
d'autosuffisance agricole qui avait été
très fair en semant mise à mal par la
guerre
et puis comme pour beaucoup de
programmes de l'union européenne on est
passé du but aux moyens c'est à dire que
le moyen est devenu un but en soi alors
un moyen qui est devenu un but en soi
dans l'europe et qui est aujourd'hui
totalement délétère c'est la concurrence
aujourd'hui le fait qu' on ériger une
statue au dieu marché et que s'il n'y a
pas de concurrence séquencier prix de
travers c'est un truc qui est en train
de nous envoyer dans le mur en ce qui
concerne le plein au pôle naturel
l'électricité le transport ferroviaire
adhérents machine à détruire du capital
cette concurrence est là bas
il n'y avait pas de questions là dessus
mais enfin bon je peux être le prochain
facebook la rive on pourrait disserter
là dessus et puis il ya donc
l'agriculture donc aujourd'hui
l'agriculture
alors on a progressivement fait un
deuxième pilier mais qui ne peut pas
mobiliser la totalité ou la majorité on
va dire des ressources de la politique
agricole alors que le système que je
propose conduirait probablement à voir
l'essentiel des ressources qu'ils soient
affectés qu'ils soient sous conditions
environnementales ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui mais là il ya un vrai
sujet qui est d'arriver à changer les
règles européennes
faute de quoi malheureusement je pense
que l'europe impose un donc je pense que
la grande bretagne ne sera qu est la
première sur la liste alors à l'époque
où la grande-bretagne est sorti je sais
que tout le monde dit de gounod et où
j'avais faire ça tout où les gens toute
l'intelligentsia parisienne que je
pouvais fréquenté à cette époque là soit
n'y croyais pas soit n'en avais pas
envie et en fait quand il n'y croyais
pas ce qu'ils ont je me rappelle très
bien de l'ambassadeur de grande bretagne
en france nous dire je suis pas ça
devait être quinze jours avant le vote
dans un événement auquel je participais
dire les sondages sont formels il y aura
pas de poids le site donc le je pense
qu'en ce moment l'italie est pas bien du
tout il ya un vrai sujet italien alors
ça sera peut-être pas la fin de l'europe
mais en tout cas ça sera peut-être la
fin de l'euro et je ne suis pas du tout
sûr que dans les dix ans qui viennent on
va pas avoir un autre grand pays
européen qu'il a quitté la plage
et à ce moment ça va commencer à être un
peu en ken groll qu'est ce que ça peut
vouloir dire tout ça ça peut vouloir
dire aussi que peut-être qu'il ya des
bras de fer a initié à partir de mai
mais pour initier un bras de fer faut
avoir une très forte volonté domestique
donc là on est renvoyé aussi à un autre
sujet c'est que là la france a toujours
traité l'europe par dessus la jambe
la france a un péché d'orgueil
absolument monstrueux en ce qui concerne
l'europe qui consiste à dire si nous on
a raison toute façon les autres
s'aligneront dessus c'est pas la peine
d'aller faire le service après vente
c'est pas la peine d'aller transpiré
pour expliquer qu'on a raison nous avons
raison donc ça s'imposera d'évidence
alors l'europe ça marche pas du tout
comme ça l'europe c'est des compromis
l'europe c'est de la persuasion l'europe
c'est des alliances de circonstance sur
des mesures concrètes
et donc ça marche pas du tout sur un
rapport d'autorité ou en tout cas pas
quand on s'appelle la france ça ne ne
fonctionne pas i petites choses que
certains d'entre vous ont peut être déjà
entendu dire la représentation française
auprès de la commission est plus petit
numériquement que la seule
représentation du land de bavière auprès
du cru vision on en voit l'europe les
clampins dont on veut plus sur la scène
politique domestique enfin bon c'est à
quelques exceptions près c'est à peu
près comme ça qu'on gère la la la chose
européenne
c'est évident que dans ce genre de
circonstance avant que l'on fasse passer
des bonnes idées à l'europe les français
peut toujours rêver donc un des sujets
qu'on doit à voir d'urgence dans ces
époques qui vont s'avérer
particulièrement troublé
c'est si on pense que les français ont
de bonnes idées sur la façon d'avancer
sur la décarbonation sur l'agriculture
et c'est un des trucs qu'il faut
absolument qu'on fasse c'est qu'on
accepte que nos impôts servent à payer
un peu plus de monde pour aller discuter
avec les instances européennes discuter
avec les autres représentants des autres
pays à l'europe et qu'on est un peu plus
les moyens de notre politique
ou plus exactement les moyens de
persuasion que nous n'avons aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui l'europe en ce qui
concerne la france est un peu regarder
passer les trains
et on y va vraiment en ordre dispersé et
en village gaulois et c'est absolument
pas productif ça c'est à mon sens le
plus gros écueil en ce qui concerne les
bonnes idées qu'on pourrait avoir sur
l'agriculture c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
est à supposer que domestiquement soient
convaincus de choses qui seraient un peu
révolutionnaire il ya strictement aucun
moyen aujourd'hui de les faire passer
rapidement à l'europe qui est un endroit
où nous ne sommes pas outillés pour
faire passer rapidement des idées
quand on pense qu'elles sont pas des
jeux je répète une chose qu'il paraît
essentiel la physique est plus forte que
les voix humaines
donc on sait bien ce n'est pas l'esprit
je viens de voir passer un commentaire
là l'union ne voudra jamais ça ce que
veut l'union est nécessairement quelque
chose de plus faible que ce que la
tectonique des plaques 1 va ramener
comme conséquence si on suit une
évolution en ligne de pente donc si on
continue à ne pas s'occuper sérieusement
de notre agriculture et à ne pas
remettre des gens dans les campagnes et
à ne pas remettre de la valeur ajoutée
dans les exploitations agricoles ce qui
va se passer en ligne de pente
c'est qu'on va voir l'accélération des
mécanismes destructeur encore une fois
tel que celui qu'on est en train de
vivre en ce moment qui vont être à
l'oeuvre ou vont être les chômeurs après
le co lead il pas dans les campagnes les
agriculteurs ils auront toujours de quoi
bouffer ils seront toujours l'exploitant
agricole bon alors il y en a
quelques-uns qui vont avoir du mal à
laisser leur pêche mais voilà ils seront
un peu aidé par les collectivités les
chômeurs et mois est essentiellement
dans les villes aujourd'hui donc les
gens qui à la suite de la crise du colis
devons plus avoir de quoi bouffer ils
seront dans les villes ça va être les
employés des restaurants qui vont fermer
ça va être les employés des commerces
qui vont fermer ça va être les employés
des parcs d'attraction qui vont être
licenciés c'est parce qu'ils sont dans
les villes
ces gens là donc si l'union européenne
entre guillemets ne veut pas au nom de
la concurrence et j'ai pas quoi qu'on
s'organise de façon intelligente dans un
monde contre 1 ce qui va se passer c'est
que il y aura des mécanismes de fond
beaucoup plus puissants et notamment le
désespoir qui va finir par porter des
populistes qui le feront ni une ni deux
et dix ans l'europe c'est très bien donc
il ya mais pour convaincre la
technostructure européenne qu'ils sont
en train de jouer avec le feu à
s'arcbouter sur des choses qui sont
contre productives
je le redis il faut avoir des troupes il
faut avoir une capacité de persuasion il
faut le vouloir
et pour le moment la france n'a pas les
troupes et la france ne veut pas donc il
ne se passe rien un point commun
comment organiser l'exode urbain ça je
pense que j'ai répondu à cette question
[Musique]
il y en avait qui me plaisait l'analyste
ne me rappelle plus où elle était
j'étais alors à il ya une question sur
la dépendance de l'économie à la
fermeture des frontières l'ouverture des
frontières la mondialisation est un
phénomène qui n'est pas nouveau c'est à
dire que des échanges marchands allons
porter ça fait un moment qu'il y en a ce
qui est récent dans l'histoire du monde
sait que ces échanges marchands allons
porter porte sur des denrées qui sont
vitales et non substituables à court
terme
alors je vais donner quelques exemples
je vais commencer par la grande-bretagne
la grande bretagne n'est pas
autosuffisante sur le plan alimentaire
donc la grande bretagne a dit c'est pas
grave je me mets dans le jeu de la
mondialisation j'apporte ma bouffe
si demain matin les échanges à longue
portée de vienne contre 1 est bien la
grande bretagne n'a plus assez à manger
alors il ya des pays qui sont dans des
situations encore plus dramatique
tous les pays du maghreb qui sont en
état d'insuffisance alimentaire
domestique à commencer par l'egypte sont
des pays qui sont dépendants des flux
logistiques à l'emporter donc de la
mondialisation
donc à partir du moment où il ya de la
fermeture de frontières
oui effectivement il ya des fonctions
qui risque d'être mise en cause et qui
sont importantes ce qui est une manière
de dire que du coup on fermera pas les
frontières à court terme à partir du
moment où c'est indispensable à ce que
le pays continue à fonctionner comme il
fonctionne vous avez aujourd'hui
énormément de grandes entreprises si ce
n'est la totalité des grandes
entreprises qui ont une dépendance à des
chaînes logistiques longue qui sont
extrêmement fortes
donc il va y avoir dans les années qui
viennent une crispation et une
opposition forte entre la pression
populaire qui a senti le vent du boulet
et qui lie au lala il faut que l'on
rapatrié qu'on relocalise et les
problèmes de court terme qui font qu'à
court terme les tops
un foutu de faire ça c'est à dire qu'une
fois que vous avez eu une usine de
construction automobile au maroc
vous n'allez pas le rapatrier en france
en quinze jours faire un hôpital de
campagne en quinze jours l'armée sait
faire ça parce qu'il ya très longtemps
qu'elle est équipée pour faire ce genre
de choses mais construire une pluie
d'obus dans quinze jours vous savez pas
faire ça et encore moins construire en
quinze jours une usine qui va faire non
pas des automobiles mais des vélos
électriques
vous avez donc un vrai problème pour
réorganiser la société il faut il faut
bien voir que la société dans laquelle
nous vivons elle a bénéficié de deux
siècles d'accumulation d'énergie
croissante et donc ça se détricote pas
en une semaine c'est bien tout problème
soit dit en passant c'est que si on
n'anticipe pas le détricotage sur des
échelles de temps très longue
là au moment où le détricotage se fait
sur des échelles de temps courte parce
que c'est ça qui est ça qui se passe
sinon ça fait énormément de dégâts je ne
sais pas du tout donc je ne n'ai pas
d'avis personnel aujourd'hui sûr on va
se situer le déplacement du curseur et
le déplacement du point d'équilibré
entre la volonté populaire qui est de
dire je voudrais que ce soit plus locale
et la possibilité matérielle des
entreprises de faire plus local et le
consentement du consommateur à payer
plus cher ce qui coûtera nécessairement
plus cher parce que la raison première
de la mondialisation c'est d'avoir
profité du pétrole pour aller chercher
du travail pas cher là où il y en avait
donc à partir du moment où vous revenez
dans le pays pour produire un truc avant
vous produisiez ailleurs vous avez un
sujet sur le coût du travail
donc ça ça revient quelque part à ce que
le pouvoir d'achat réel dix minutes
c'est à dire qu avec la même fiche de
paye mais ça nous renvoie au début cette
discussion avec la même fiche de paye
vous poseriez la possibilité d'acheter
moins de choses aujourd'hui ouvertement
la mondialisation des dernières
décennies
ah si je le dis un peu de façon courte a
ruiné le salarié est satisfait le
consommateur c'est à dire qu'on a
supprimé du travail aux français
par contre on leur a permis de consommer
plus de choses alors tant que cette
mondialisation nous a aussi profité
parce que on a appris à faire des choses
qui bénéficient à l'économie mondialisée
notamment des avions pas que des sacs à
main aussi et bien et des bouteilles de
vin et bien cher pas cher se mondialise
par mais le vin chez r oui et bien
quelque part on profitait de nos
avantages concurrentiels à dos et ont
profité
c'était meilleur des deux mondes de
l'augmentation de notre pouvoir d'achat
lié au fait qu'on allait faire
travailler les chinois puis des
thaïlandais puis des habitants du
bangladesh pour produire les biens de
consommation non nous avons besoin plus
avec des commandes pour lequel nous
avons des désirs solvable à partir du
moment où on n'a plus cette marge de
manoeuvre du travail paie cher eh bien
ça veut dire que le prix réel des
produits va se mettre à réaugmenter donc
il faut que le consommateur comprenne ce
que plus d'actes manquantes le citoyen
réclame une relocalisation on comprenne
bien que ça va avec un système qui les
deux fait un système de contraction de
son pouvoir d'achat
et ça veut dire qu'ils acceptent de fait
que la société s'organise autour de ce
genre de tendance
je le redis je pense pour ma part que
c'est totalement inexorable donc je
pense que le consommateur a raison le
combat de sénateurs citoyens à raison
s'il dit je pense que c'est ça qui est
pertinent mais je je il faut bien
comprendre que c'est ça la contrepartie
j'ai une vraie frustration
la question ne va pas été posée mais
j'ai une vraie frustration dans la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
c'est alors non pas parce que j'ai mes
chevilles mais c'est de ne pas avoir eu
l'occasion de me retrouver face à eux
pour leur dire
voilà ce que je crois fondamentalement
ans sur le lien entre énergie et
l'économie et est ce que vous seriez
capable de réfléchir à votre hiérarchie
des renoncements votre votre expression
de choix collectivement dans un monde
dans lequel le pouvoir d'achat se
contracte non pas parce que nos
politiques sont des abrutis
mais malheureusement parce que c'est
l'évolution à laquelle on sera tous
confrontés dans un monde qui est peuplée
de 8 milliards d'habitants ayant tous
envie de consommer et vraiment c'est une
grosse frustration parce que c'est un
contexte dans lequel je suis sûr qu'on
aurait eu affaire à une réponse sans
arrière pensée peut-être que les gens
auraient dit banon se fait péter la
panse tant qu'on peut vous n'y pensez
pas et c'est peut-être qu'ils auraient
dit non au contraire
vraiment il faut que ça soit sur des
planches à dessin et que comme le
politique n'aura jamais le courage de
s'y attaquer de lui même dont on nous
force on se force à réfléchir à ce
problème qui est après de difficiles
tawake douloureux mais qu'on comprend
bien être un problème inévitable j'avoue
que j'ai une énorme frustration à ce
titre est bon sans être méchant je pense
que on est un peu trop rester dans le
politiquement correct dans ce genre
d'exercice
et peut-être que finalement il faudrait
alors je ne sais pas qui aurait les
moyens de faire ça un jour faire une
conférence des citoyens sur la question
comment gérer un monde en décroissance
peut-être que finalement c'est pas une
mauvaise idée
ça permettrait d'avoir un exercice un
peu formalisés donc on sait à peu près
ce qu'on en sort et on peut tester comme
ça dans un cadre j'ai envie dira
politique sans que les gens pensent
qu'on est en train de les en fléau
histoire de favori et nos catégories de
flancher les gens sur pourquoi c'est une
hypothèse de travail pays hôte et
malheureusement pas idiote parents et
comment est ce que dans ce genre de
contexte
on retrouve le se donne un projet qui
est un projet auquel on accède de
souscrire voilà je trouve dommage qu'on
ait raté cette opportunité parce que le
temps file et que je sais pas quand
est-ce qu'on est là qu'on la retrouve
bon tout ça ça nous éloigne ça vous
emmène très très loin encore que pas
tant que ça de la longueur des déchets
tu des chaînes logistiques
alors avec quoi est-ce que je vais
terminer pompom
tout ça on a répondu ça j'aurais entendu
ça j'ai répondu ça j'ai répondu ça j'ai
répondu allez je vais finir avec ça
pensez vous qu après les crises
actuelles ariel changements pourraient
être opérés ou repartir en août poubelle
alors j'ai répondu tout à l'heure sur le
fait que je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
repartir de plus belle parce que nous
appelons plafond énergétique qui va
s'appliquer en tout cas en france
bonne question en forme exactement
l'autre question à laquelle je vais
répondre maintenant c est ce que la
crise du coc vide permet de cristalliser
de façon un peu violente compréhension
du fait qu'il ya des limites et qu'il
faut en tenir compte
voilà c'est plutôt sur la question à
laquelle j'ai envie de répondre dit
autrement
à partir du moment où on utilise le mot
crise et c'est dur est dans la question
1 pensez vous qu après les crises
actuelles une crise c'est un processus
c'est un phénomène pardon qui par
construction et transitoires d'accord
une crise c'est quelque chose qui a un
début et c'est quelque chose qui a une
fin derrière une crise
vous retrouvez la situation que vous
aviez avant par exemple quand vous avez
une crise d'adolescence et bien avant
l'adolescence vous êtes serein vous êtes
un gamin la ville rose après
l'adolescence vous êtes un adulte
équilibré bien entre les deux vous ptp
voilà ça c'est par construction
transitoire on se dit qu'à un moment ça
se termine il reste quand on vit à faire
on est on regarde pas mais content que
ça se termine quand on l'a fait
rencontre le je crois que la situation
dans laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui
n'est pas une crise je crois que c'est
une marche d'escalier
même si ça n'a rien à voir en apparence
avec l'énergie et le climat
je pense que je le redis nous sommes
dans un processus correctif parmi
d'autres de type callas
on pas voir la limite et à un moment la
limite s'applique à douala donc je ne
crois pas que ce soit une crise donc la
question c'est est-ce que cette
conviction que j'ai qui est que je ne
prends pas que ce soit une crise va être
partagée par suffisamment de gens pour
comme je le disais tout à l'heure faire
masse et du coup peser sur l'exécutif
alors comme je suis un indécrottable
optimiste j'ai envie de dire beaucoup
plus qu'en 2008 et 2009 parce que la
question a aussi été posées sur est-ce
que vous pensez que ça va pas repartir
de plus belle comme en 2008 je pense que
cette crise actuelle n est pas du tout
perçue comme la crise de 2008 et 2009
la crise de 2008 et 2009 pouvait être
mise sur une catégorie d'acteurs les
banquiers et les financiers qui avaient
fait absolument n'importe quoi les
autres n'avaient rien à se reprocher
même si je pense que la situation était
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça donc on
tape un grand coup sûr les banquiers et
puis ça part comme avant là on a atteint
le monde réel c'est à dire que la virus
ça fait partie du monde réel c'est pas
une crise financière
des gens qui sont malades ça fait partie
du monde réel et une économie qu'on met
à l'arrêt ça fait partie du monde réel
sais tu sais on voit bien que les choses
se passent pas comme et que ça concerne
tout le monde partout et tout le temps
et c'est pas juste quelqu'un qui a fait
une connerie dans un coin bon alors on
pourrait dire qu'il suffit dernier perd
de tuer les braqueurs de lait des
braconniers de pangolin et de tuer les
gens qui achètent des pangolins vont
très bien et les chauves souris mais
mais mais bon globalement il ya un côté
faute à pas de chance qui apparaît
beaucoup plus fortement dans cette crise
que dans la crise précédente qui avait
un coupable tout désigné
du coup ça invite probablement beaucoup
plus de gens à réfléchir parce que quand
c'est la faute à pas de chance vous vous
demandez quand même si en fait vous
n'avez pas été un peu imprudent
quand la faute à pas de chance soulagée
j'ai pas été assez vigilant la prochaine
fois je me méfierais un peu plus
alors certes dans la crise actuelle on
va quand même pouvoir blâmer les les
gens qui ont pas fait les stocks de
masques les mais je le redis il ya quand
même un côté faute à pas de chance
par ailleurs depuis 2008 il ya quand
même 12 ans de discours alarmistes sur
l'état du monde qui sont passés par là
et que je tends fils trois ou quatre
rapports
du world economic forum qui disent que
la planète c'est vraiment important mais
participants de change strictement rien
derrière
ils s'en foutent complètement pour
l'essentiel d'entre vous font des
discours de façade qui sont totalement
farfelue il ya eu un certain nombre de
mouvements de jeunesse la jeunesse c'est
quand même beau gosse
donc on regarde ça d'un peu près enfin
en tout cas les miens il ya eu un
certain nombre déjà de petits accidents
et le prix du pétrole est monté puis
redescendu pierre montée puis on s'est
demandé s'il y en avait et puis et c'est
enfin bon donc le discours qu'il a eue
les incendies en australie il ya
quelques mois répit et donc donc le
discours sur ou ça commence à sentir le
roussi a quand même beaucoup progressé
alors il faut pas se faire d'illusions
en ce qui concerne tous les gens qui
vont perdre leur job dans les mois à
venir
parce que je pense que malheureusement
il va y avoir quelques millions tous les
gens qui aussi dans les mois à venir ont
vraiment l'impression d'être les
laissés-pour-compte de la reprise
parce que je pense qu'il va y avoir le
vrai problème il n'est pas maintenant on
est haut possible dans l'effort où on a
de la compréhension de mon a de
l'empathie où on est c'est le vrai
problème il va être quand dans quelques
mois certains vont se retrouver au
chômage et white l'impression d'être
totalement largué qu'on les ait
absolument pas sortir de la merde quand
dans quelques mois une partie du
patronat va se dire
moi j'ai mis la clé sous la porte
personne ne vit rarement secours qu'est
ce qui se passe alors qu'air france sont
là des milliards et c'est à ce moment là
que ça va commencer à tanguer sévère et
c'est à ce moment là qu'il va falloir
que les gens qui ont compris qu'on était
dans un changement de paradigme est
suffisamment de prise sur le système
pour être capable à la fois de contenir
cette détresse être capable de tracer
les voies pour l'avenir et être capable
d'influer sur insuffisamment grands
corpus de la société pour qu'on y
partent dans cette voie pour l'avenir
donc la question c'est est-ce qu'on a
suffisamment changé les mentalités à la
fois chez les gens qui seront pas dans
la plus grande détresse et qui eux vont
devoir s'y prendre autrement chez les
gens qui sont dans la plus et pardon et
chez tous les décideurs et les corps
intermédiaires qui eux vont devoir avoir
envie qu'on s'y prenne autrement donc
c'est ça la question pour moi c est ce
que on a suffisamment de gens qui
aujourd'hui ont vraiment envie qu'on s'y
prenne autrement dans les corps
intermédiaires et là ma dernière réponse
sera malheureusement pour vous je n'en
sais rien tout simplement parce que
chacun voit midi à sa porte j'ai déjà
dit plusieurs fois ici il faut se défier
des effets de communautarisme moi je
fréquente par construction des gens qui
s'intéressent à mon sujet les clients de
carbone 4 s'intéresse un peu à mon sujet
ce qui ce qui s'en fiche comme de l'an
40 je ne les vois pas je vois un peu
aussi des gens qui sont très hostiles à
mon sujet cela je les vois arriver en
réaction sur des postes linkedin ou
celle quoi le ventre mou je le vois pas
de même que shift tout ce que je vois
arriver c'est des gens qui s'intéressent
à mon sujet et les gens qui continuent à
envoyer des commentaires après deux
heures là ici je pense qu'ils
s'intéressent suffisamment à mon sujet
pour ne pas être occupé à faire autre
chose donc le donc je me méfie beaucoup
de cette effet de communautarisme et du
coup de l'optimisme que ça peut
déclencher parce que vous vous dites
assez génial il ya plein de gens qui
s'intéressent à mon sujet donc mon sujet
est très important la vérité c'est que
je n'en sais rien la deuxième vérité
c'est que je ne fais absolument pas
confiance aux sondages pour me dire si
c'est important ou pas parce que les
sondages la réponse est dans la question
donc
il suffit de poser la bonne question
vous avez la bonne réponse je me
rappelle rien ce qui est des paroles
dans le monde il ya quelques années et
sétaient est-ce que vous avez les
énergies ce que vous êtes favorable aux
énergies renouvelables et 90% des
français a répondu oui
moi j'aurais répondu oui aussi du reste
suffit de choisir les bonnes et le la
seule question c'est est-ce et qui c'est
qui les en domino pense encore répondu
non et qu'ils sont pareils cas pourquoi
donc le le sondage ne donne strictement
aucune indication sur en fait la
hiérarchisation réel que les gens sont
prêts à faire sur les divers problèmes
et des divers efforts
pas grand chose voilà donc l'après
question c'est est-ce que les mentalités
changent
alors je peux plus peut finir avec ce
tout petit espoir je ne crois pas que ce
soit un effet de notoriété
il se trouve qu chief project on a notre
effet club où on a cherché à faire un
club depuis des années donc on fait
notre petit davos haddou et chaque année
on essaye de draguer un certain nombre
de chefs d'entreprises en leur disant
venez donc discuté pendant 24 heures
avec nous alors je suis désolé pour tous
les communistes trotskistes et autres
qui nous regardent
on fait ça dans un lieu pour riches dans
un petit chaton 28 relais et châteaux il
faut aller chercher les gens là où ils
sont mais le point important c'est que
quand on a démarré ce truc là
allez on avait des vrais chefs
d'entreprises qui sont venus à première
heure on a eu quatre à quatre ou cinq à
la dernière édition du forum qu'on a
annulé pour cause de coran des virus on
en avait une petite cinquantaine et dans
les 50
on avait un certain nombre de numéro 1
ou 2 de société soit du 4 40 soit
équivalent donc ça j'ai envie de penser
et quand vous commencez à déplacer des
gens comme ça pendant 24 heures
je vous assure pour les connaître un peu
que c'est pas juste pour vos beaux yeux
que l'hygiène et c'est pas juste parce
qu'il vous aime bien c'est qu'ils ont
vraiment commencé à placer ce sujet un
peu haut sur leur agenda au moins en
terme 2 où il faudrait que je trouve ça
d'un peu plus près donc ça c'est un tout
petit signe d'espoir que qui me laissent
penser qu' il n'est pas complètement
exclu que l'on puisse avoir un peu
changé les mentalités depuis 2008 et qu'
il est un peu des coûts et en
particulier un nombre croissant gens qui
se disent la paix quand la crise due
qu'au guidon est vraiment enfin de
surfer avec l'épisode coheed local faïz
on est vraiment en train de se prendre
un we call et il faut vraiment qu'on
commence à se resserrer sur la façon
dont on va réorganiser la façon dont
fonctionne pour l'avenir
il commence à y avoir mis le feu au lac
comme disent nos amis helvètes dont une
partie regardent peut-être
voilà donc je vais finir sur cette
réponse là en disant est ce que ça a
changé
je ne sais pas est-ce qu'on peut essayer
de capitaliser sur ce qu'ils pensent
vraiment que ça commence à sentir le
roussi pour essayer d'accélérer la
cadence là la réponse est évidemment
mille fois oui et c'est à ça qu'on va
essayer de s'employer au schiste project
dans les mois qui viennent voilà et bien
écoutez les plus grands à votre journal
télévisé même s'il n'y a pas de patron
ce soir je vous souhaite une bonne fin
de soirée
merci à ceux qui sont restés calmes ans
jusqu'à maintenant et à une prochaine
fois pas au revoir